You guys couldn't hear the music!
No!
Why does this go so hard?
You hear the chatter expressing frustration.
That was
the AI message.
I got you.
Thanks, Viper!
Oh my god!
Because my voice is not very warmed up today yet, so...
Sorry.
I'm just drinking my first tea, also.
Did you make this game?
I might as well, right?
Oh,
God.
Sorry, I'm like, so...
If you don't know, this company is called Curate, right?
And they make every single one of my favorite games ever.
If you know the Bunny Girl...
I have to turn it down just a little bit.
If you know the Bunny Girl Cafe game...
What was it called?
Bunny Garden?
They made that, too.
They made a Bunny Garden.
So, you know, sometimes their games kind of blow up.
Oh, boy.
Yeah.
They made Bunny.
garden uh-huh but this one is like a vampire survivor type
game so i'm very excited oh kaiten sushi wait so this is
akibo station right this kaiten sushi place this uh rotating
sushi place is actually it's not there anymore it's been
it's gone now unfortunately is this a spicy game then
Yes.
Can you put yourself at the end of the maid lineup?
Like down here?
I'm in the game!
Oh, wait.
There we- wait.
I'm covering the logo, though.
Not as spicy as Bunny Garden or the Days games.
This one!
I think this one is pretty spicy still, though.
I don't think bunny garden was that spicy from what I saw of
it but I think they didn't have a green made so true I think
this one has some good spice I think this one has some good
spice in it a bunny garden besides like the panny shots
sometimes it wasn't that bad but curate games can get pretty
I think that's also why it blew up a little bit.
You know?
It was more friendly for...
Other people to play.
The mainstream masses, maybe.
But no, I'm a freak.
I want to play.
The etchier, the better.
Yeah, more YouTube accessible.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
um but uh i don't i don't know so much about this game i try
to you know i've been wanting to play it since the day i saw
that it was announced though i was just like this game is
made for me so
i thought about you when i saw this game thank you for
thinking about me
same company made like treble days which also went kind of
viral and oh
and also the hotel izanami hotel they they kind of they make
such like such a wide variety which I really like and
they're always kind of changing like with kind of gameplay
so I appreciate that too live stream Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
I love Etsy games!
But this one is about maids.
It takes place in Akihabara.
And I actually really like Vampire Survivor type games.
I haven't played Vampire Survivors.
Am I tilted?
Can't tell.
Anyway.
I haven't played Vampire Survivors itself, but I've played
Vampire Survivor type games.
I really like them, so...
Eye tracker!
Oh!
I can't do the eye tracker!
No!
My setup for it is on the other monitor.
I can't...
Oh no!
Thank you, Mint!
Excited to watch this.
Yippee!
Thanks for the iron cyber!
Thank you!
Dang.
Maybe if I play it again, um...
I just got here.
What is this game?
Well, it's a vampire survivor type game.
game with etchy maids and some visual novel aspects.
No eye tracker needed right now.
Let's just get into it though.
It happened suddenly without warning.
There wasn't even enough time to try and comprehend what was
going on.
The only thing that was certain was that some people had
lost their minds and started attacking others.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know why my voice is very weird today.
As our peaceful lives started to slowly crumble around us,
all we could do was run.
It's weird.
Yeah, my voice is really raspy for you.
I think because I just woke up.
Well, I didn't just wake up.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm blocking.
Look at the guy I'm blocking.
And this guy over here, he has like the pen lights and
everything.
Those do not look like normal pen lights, though.
Those look like...
Traff...
Or like plain traffic lights.
Akihab Buddha.
Yeah, it's Akihab Buddha.
Look, we have games.
instead of gamers.
Gao X.
So funny.
The maid even.
So cute.
But the pachinko and slot stays there, baby.
Hobby Paradise.
Hokes instead of Vox.
Vox.
I mean, sorry.
This way is no good, too.
There seems to be a lot of zombie-looking things here as
well we can't give up rinka it has to be an escape route
somewhere yeah i know
but we can't stay outside like this we'll be hunted down in
no time maybe it'd be better to seek shelter in a building
or something.
Nagisa, can you walk?
I think Nagisa is the type to be bit and then, um, I just
met her, but I think she's the type to be bit and not tell
anybody.
Then let's go.
Nagisa's gonna die!
No!
We won't let any of our precious maids die.
Oh, they're made out of it.
They're so cute.
I like the ribbons.
They're like cross ribbons on this one.
Oh, you can't see.
This seems like a good place to hide for now, yeah?
Oh my god, we're at Tollies!
I mean...
Ollies?
Have you played any of the Akiba's trip games?
I've heard.
I've also heard of the anime...
Also, have you heard of the anime ZOM 100?
I have heard of the anime ZOM 100, but I have not watched
it.
And yes, I've played Akiba's trip.
I have.
She's already turning.
Looks good.
Just gonna close my eyes and rest for a bit.
Oh, God, Nagisa!
Oh, my God.
She's about to die, for real.
Oh, Nagisa?
Uh-oh.
Nagisa?
She's bitten for sure.
I'm fine, really.
You're not fine at all.
There's no way this is from a sprained ankle.
Trust me, I'm okay.
Just a little bit tired from having to compensate for my
ankle.
That's all.
If you're sure, Ogar Rinka, run!
Run!
Oh,
no.
Either way, it might be a bit difficult to continue and try
to outrun them.
They're quicker than they look.
You're not.
You're right, and I don't really have the confidence with
this leg of mine.
What do you think those zombies like things are anyway?
You don't think we got trapped on a movie set or something,
do you?
Wasn't that a TV show like a Korean TV show where they had
people like sign up and think that they were going on a
different type of reality show and then they like, actually
instead it was supposed to be like, like they were like a
zombie apocalypse happened.
And that feels very illegal.
I meant I can't wait to finally meet you at Otak!
Otak!
I'll come to the meet and greet cosplay with you as you with
a twist.
I hope you can accept gifts.
I made a cute skirt and hair bow.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited to see!
Sounds familiar.
I think it was that, right, though?
And then they were just like, oh my gosh.
gosh instead of it was a but I think it had to be very
obviously like it's not a real zombie apocalypse or else
you'd really panic but you know the green maid in the bottom
right is defo a freak what do you think those zombie like
things are anyway you don't think we got oh movies chat
that's right people wouldn't be dying on a movie set besides
Akihabara is in total chaos I guess you have a point.
A guitarist is shredding.
Right!
All we know is that being bitten by one of them will also
turn you into a zombie!
Before we know it, Akihabara could be filled with zombies!
I hope everyone at the main cafe was able to make it out.
Okay, this is the sequel to Akiba Made Wars, everybody.
Who knows?
I mean, we were handing... we were out-handing flyers, so
it's hard to say what happened.
All we can do is pray.
Actually got the fans up in this game, Grace.
It's only a matter of time before they make it here, too.
We need to find a safe place to take shelter.
Hey, Rinka, it's okay to leave me behind.
Now's not the time for jokes.
You know that I won't be able to run with this leg of mine,
but you can, right?
She just doesn't want to tell her that she's been bit.
But she's definitely been bit.
She just so wants to lessen the guilt.
Bless him, bless him, bless it.
I'm not trying to be a hero or anything.
I just think it'd be better for you to go on ahead.
A heyed.
To look for help for the both of us.
No, I can't do that.
Why not?
You know deep down it's the right thing to do, I'm just
gonna drag you down like this.
Both of you are helping me out.
I'm just going to help each other.
Splitting up for a bit is what's best for the both of us.
Also, let me know if the audio is okay.
I've been trying to have it not be so loud, but also so you
can make sure you hear it.
Whoever gets me a sub, thank you!
Thank you for the Super Chat boost!
Thank you!
Two EU-friendly streams in a week?
Am I losing it?
Hello!
Hello?
There's no other option, Nagisa.
Whoa.
Look here?
Uh-oh.
Did Rinka get bit?
Ah!
Oh, uh...
Rinka, chan...
It's...
Where?
Wait!
We were wrong, you guys!
What a twist!
The Inka!
Wait, when did... How did this happen?
How did you not...
You have no lo- How did you not notice this?
...
Sorry, I'm trying not to be a sensor, you know.
Just get me off the screen.
Here, here, here.
Everybody, take your peek.
Get your sneak peek.
Get your little, get your little fill.
I don't know how her skirt's doing that, to be honest,
but...
Thank you, Minto.
You're welcome.
I think I was bitten earlier while running away.
I can feel myself starting to lose control.
No, why?
I think I'm going to lose my mind.
Oh.
Soon enough, I'll lose control and become just like those
zombies.
There's a big chance I'll attack you too.
If you press it, if you click on it, nothing happens.
Wait,
I did say Rinka's line, right?
She's going to run away and lure them away.
You don't need to do that.
Sorry, Nagisa.
Wouldn't it be so funny if Nagisa went like, But Rinka, and
then showed her her bite too, and was just like, I'm also
bitten.
Fight me, Rinka.
Oh my gosh.
Calm.
Down, boy.
Down, down.
Down, boy, down.
You just met her.
Promise me you'll live for my sake, too.
Spaghetti.
Wait, please.
Rinka, Chan!
Rinka!
Oh, no.
I watch.
As my life crumbled around me.
I was just...
...hanging...
...I was just...
...I could do was reach my hand out to Rinka's back...
...as it slipped further and further away from me.
...DOOM DURY.
Oh!
...Rinka, she was happy and healthy...
...and not a zombie.
Wait, are we gonna see her, like, transform?
...YOKATTA!
...You're all right!
...
...Linka, ...
...Rinka, ...
She's dreaming about her.
I'm begging you.
Stop,
this looks just like Krebskule, maid cafe.
Oh, is everything okay then?
It was a dream?
You're finally awake.
It seems.
Oh!
Oh my god,
she's so cute!
She's so cute!
Oh my god, stop.
I swear, the art keeps getting better and better in these
games.
Mint color.
This game was made for me!
Who are you?
How would I end up in such a place?
It seems like you're a bit confused, but I guess that's to
be expected after being involved in such a pandemic.
I'd be surprised if you weren't.
A pandemic?
I'm Kanon Mikagami.
I thought this shop would be a good place to hide, but you
seem to have found it first.
I've hatched you up a bit.
Pandemic.
I think this is more like an epidemic.
I think we're in big trouble.
The shop?
Oh, right.
You mean the smith cafe?
This is a maid cafe.
used to work here actually.
DLC?
Cure it, please sponsor me!
Pandemic is bigger than an epidemic though?
Is it actually?
Wait, I always thought that it was the opposite.
I thought epidemic was the worst one.
I'd call it an apocalypse.
Oh, epidemic is more small.
Oh!
I thought panic...
Oh, everything.
Oh,
epidemic.
I think, to me, it just sounds like Epidemic.
This is so...
So in my brain, I'm just like...
It's epically bad.
So that's why I always thought that it was worse than
pandemic.
Kind of makes sense.
Though it doesn't.
An epic-demic.
I guess after splitting with Rinka, I ran all the way out
here without realizing, oh god, are we gonna have to fight
Rinka?
What if she's, what if Rinka is immune, you know?
Luckily, there were no zombies around, so I took the time to
set some precautions up.
I've decided to use this place as my base.
The SSR dummy.
This is from the live stream devs.
Yep, yep, yep.
I spent the whole day setting up the fence and doing some
maintenance.
But it should be worth it to keep the zombies away.
Oh, Yenwei, thank you.
Easy to remember, Pan, like pen-sexual.
Oh, thank you.
Freaky damek.
Seems like a majority of survivors are people who don't wear
pants.
True!
I wonder if there's a lot of survivors in Scotland.
You're right, it does look a bit different.
Wait, you said you did all of this in one day?
How long were you going to be able to find you?
How long were you asleep?
To be exact, it took 28 hours and 32 minutes after finding
you and patching you up.
I've been out that long?
What happened to Akihara?
Uh-oh.
I wouldn't go out there if I were you.
The number of zombies keeps going up.
That's more of a reason to go out there and do something!
Rinka-chan- My friends are still out there maybe.
Oh,
how does she know my name?
I can't have you going off on your own, Miss Nagisa Hihara.
Did I tell you my name?
Your student ID was in your pocket.
Oh, she's a freak.
Why were you trying she was trying to rob me she was she
pickpocketed me the sleeves I know Kanon is so cute you
won't be leaving you I can't have you go out there only to
be turned into a zombie once you do why are Kanon's hands
like that why are you so rude you're an all-too-important
test subject for us one that's carrying a very specific
antibody.
Oh my god, she already, she did experiments on me in my
sleep.
Sample?
I'm a test subject?
So, very important sample.
Nagisa, you're a very rare one of that.
Why do you think those zombies suddenly appeared, Miss
Nagisa?
Um...
A movie, or something like that, an image of a virus-like
So she did get bitten, right?
That's what it sounds like, right?
Um, what are we?
Umbrella Corporation?
If we're going by movie logic, maybe an unknown virus spread
from one person to the next, or something.
This is the same thing.
This is the virus that the virus is the pandemic You got it.
It's believed...
Sorry.
It's believed that the reason these zombies appeared in
Akihabara is because of a pandemic causing virus.
From what we know so far, the only way for this virus to
spread is their bodily fluid from zombie to person.
That's why zombie bites are so deadly.
If there's saliva or blood enters your system, it's game
over.
The panty shot.
I really smooched.
zombies.
From my observations, it seems most infected humans will
transform instantly, though the latest is a couple of hours.
So Ninka started to turn pretty quickly, she said.
She was starting to lose control.
So we did get bit.
A few individuals carry a special antibody.
Oh my gosh, maybe I should have made coffee instead of tea.
It seems like you're one of those people, Miss Nagisa.
Wait a
second, antibodies?
As in the things that protect you from getting colds?
Choo, choo, choo, choo, choo, choo, choo, choo, choo, choo,
choo, choo, choo, choo.
Precisely, this might be a bit frank.
But you've already been infected!
Yeah, we knew it!
More than likely you were bit at some point when running
away.
But for some reason your body hasn't reacted.
You're completely symptom-free, which means you must have
that antibody.
Does that mean we can make an antidote with this antibody of
mine?
That's exactly what I've been researching here.
Oh my god.
What a perfect research location.
Kiss your friend to cure.
I've made a vaccine prototype from your blood.
Oh my god, she's already taken my blood and everything.
But it'll still need to undergo some more modifications and
tests.
That's amazing!
But such a vaccine, we'd be able to turn zombies back into
humans, right?
No, it's not so many things.
Oh.
Waku waku chintin Yeah, waku waku chintin Sadly, no.
Even if we administered the vaccine to someone who was fully
turned, they wouldn't be able to revert back.
Waku waku chintin!
Waku chintin But it could be used to prevent full
transformations of people who've been bitten or prevent
someone from becoming infected.
Besides, this is nothing more than a prototype.
There are major limitations when working somewhere like
this.
I haven't even been able to test it, so I don't even know
how effective
I don't care.
Even if it was only a 1% chance, I'd still take the gamble.
What are you saying?
I told you, a friend of mine is still outside.
Oh gosh, a friend of hers, you guys.
A friend of hers.
She was bitten, but this vaccine might be able to save her
if she hasn't fully transformed.
Yeah, but Kanon, weren't you listening?
Were you even listening to what I said?
No one knows how effective this vaccine is.
And Nagisa said that she would take the 1% chance!
And your friend, Rinka, wasn't it?
Well, it's been at least 28 hours since she was bitten.
She's more than likely.
Oh,
she's more than likely to turn into a zombie, by now.
have to happen to save her.
Nagisara looks crazy right now.
She's like, I told, and I told you, didn't I?
It doesn't matter.
Even if it's a 1% chance, I'd do anything for my friend.
Seems like you won't listen to reason.
If you're going to be that way, then I'll be helping look
for Ms. Rinka to...
Nino?
Are you sure?
If you're good at being able to get the vaccine, I'm sure
you'd still sneak off with the vaccine anyway.
Okay, okay.
I think we need to be a little bit more, like, practical
about this, right?
Like, this might be the only person that we know of.
that has an antibody to this virus.
And we're just gonna let her go.
We're not gonna, we need to take, like, notes.
We need to document our research in case somebody does find
this and is able to then see everything and create a cure.
We need to take ample, ample amounts of her blood, you know,
to, like, have it as extra so that they can be continued
research.
We need Renka.
That's one of my favorite Japanese words, Buki.
If we're going outside, we'll have to prepare some weapons.
They're makeshift, but we don't have much of a choice.
Please take this.
Wait, but that's...
A gun!
Is it a salt rifle?
I'm sure you've seen what in a movie or something.
makeshift assault rifle.
It's real?
Not just like some toy?
I'd be arrested for carrying this.
Oh!
Martial law.
Obviously, the police have been infected too.
Now's not the time to worry about laws.
Please learn how to do defend yourself with it.
You made a vaccine?
I collected weapons?
Kanon.
Who exactly are you?
It's pink.
It's so cute.
Her trigger discipline, though.
Oh, she does!
Never mind!
I'm so sorry.
I thought that...
Never mind.
I made it.
It was...
Oh, it was hidden by the bar, that's why.
Wow.
Okay.
Glasses, girls, still...
Glasses, girls are cute.
So true.
Thank God!
I can't leave here as I'll be working on the vaccine, but
please contact me using this communicator if you need me.
My codec frequency is...
...
Please don't be reckless.
You're one in a million, after all.
Okay!
For starters, I need to rescue Rinka.
I can think about the rest after that.
Oh!
Tutorial time!
The main objective of any stage is to clear it while staying
away from danger.
However, each stage will have additional conditions.
Your equipped gun will automatically shoot.
Oh, okay.
The trajectory can be changed to shoot behind.
By pressing LB.
LB.
Like on my mouse?
You can lock on your shooting...
Oh, by pressing LB, you can lock on your shooting trajectory
separate to your movement.
You can switch between lock on by holding down or lock on
toggle in the options.
Is this made vampire survivors?
Yes, actually.
by pressing...
Wait, should this be played with a controller?
Uh-oh.
Close range attack.
You can attack with a close range weapon in your arsenal.
Weapons can only be used after the weapon gauge fills up.
I play mouse plus keyboard.
Oh, wait.
Choosing a skill.
Collecting powers that enemies drop will increase your
level.
You can gain new skills by choosing them when you level up.
Let's see what we got.
Grenade.
Landvine.
Special.
If the same skill is selected, its skill level will
increase.
The level cap differs based on each skill.
Some skills do not level up.
The number of skills that can increase in battle are
limited.
Some skills allow additional effects on select skills.
Choose the right skills for the right situation.
Let's see.
Support attack drone.
Yeah, it's a burst fire gun.
Oh, he'll HP auto heals wait, but I'm not hurt Increased
defense by 9% Increased movement by 5% Attack this sounds
nice though the drone Have some help Looking at me he's
going he's going for it.
Oh gosh Oh Nice.
More drone!
Decreases cooldown.
Oh, nice!
Ah!
More drone!
No way.
Oh.
More drones!
Oh my god.
I don't want to have to do any work.
Um, I think you guys know the deal.
More drones!
Oh, power increase.
Increases drone strength.
Increases...
Oh, wait.
Increases drone strength by 50%.
Never mind.
More drone!
Oh, hell yeah.
I'm so slow.
It's painful.
Okay, next thing.
If I can increase my speed...
I will do so.
I'm so slow.
Increases maximum HP.
This game looks cute, right?
Drone Chan, my beloved.
Well, we have no more drone.
Wait!
Oh.
Decreases.
Let's do...
Let's do the attack cooldown.
Die zombie!
Look at the little otaku!
Otaku
chomun!
the otaku i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i can't tell where
they're where my other drones are attacking oh my gosh
there's so many zombies over here but oh i was there's no
place i'm supposed to be going i think i just last i think i
just survive right oh oh oh there's so many oh oh nice nice
nice More drone!
Wait, a drone that circles the area while shooting
lightning?
I think we need some more drones.
Electric drone!
That's technically another drone, so...
That's technically its own drone.
Nice.
Drone flight time.
Let's do optimize.
Sorry drones.
Oh!
Okay, that was a fun little tutorial level.
Esserank.
She hates drones.
No!
Oh my god!
This is where Bik camera is.
I know exactly where this is.
This corner.
And then if you turn around, that's where the sign, like
over on this side, is the sign with the, like, the famous
at-home sign and everything.
Yeah, I know exactly where we are.
Davenpies!
Welcome to Davenpuship, thank you.
Haito station.
Me, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, is that Taito?
It is!
This is where those horrible, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma.
Those the guys are at...
Blip.
Remember the basics of CQC or just use more drones!
Wait a sec.
Don't just throw me into a horde of zombies!
This is what you wanted, isn't it?
I still don't know how to use a gun, nor have I ever trained
in any type of combat.
That's why we just use drones.
She's a superhuman.
Oh my gosh.
Thanks to the virus, you've become a lot stronger than the
average person.
Not the codec.
Get go!
Thanks for three months!
A genome soldier?
No!
Neuro-machines!
Oh yeah, I also, I made the blood purple.
So if you see the purple on the ground, I thought it would
be kind of cute.
What are the zombies doing that they're like blowing up the
top of buildings?
If you were to enter any international sports competition
right now, you'd be strong enough to win gold.
The Olympics are happening right now.
Even stronger than those military personnel over there.
I'm that strong?
I don't really feel any different.
That doesn't...
Okay, but her strength does not equate to her knowing how to
use a gun.
Purple Blood?
What is this?
Maid girl, Dangan Rompah?
Yes.
Thanks for three votes, Sarja!
Thank you for the new friendly stream.
Of course!
the way that horde of zombies, right?
Not many people could do that by themselves.
Oh my god.
She's insane!
Oh, you mentioned it.
Oh, the scratches from earlier have completely healed.
This is all because I was infected with the virus?
The virus gives you unlimited ammo.
Well, to be technical, it's because you've been spared from
the negative effects of the virus using that special
antibody inside of you.
But please remember, all your body is doing is healing
faster.
Regrowing limbs is impossible even at your current state.
So please be careful.
Oh, man, I thought I was a lizard.
Yeah, my current state?
What the heck?
I don't want to think about that.
How about you try and be a bit more comforting?
Sorry for the blip.
Obious.
If you were entering a sporting competition, you would win
gold because everyone else is dead.
Maybe the virus is a way to find super soldiers for the evil
organization behind this.
You have a point there.
You'll be fine as long as those zombies don't completely
surround you.
Please always watch your back and make sure you have an
escape rope.
I told you before, but you're one in a million sample.
If we lose you, we may never be able to make a vaccine to
counter those.
Hockey.
Nade Cafe was a good place to be able to save you.
I've fully equipped the Maid Cafe to function as a base,
resting up as a giffin, but you can also maintenance and
strengthen your weaponry here too.
Strengthening my weapons?
The weapon I gave you is designed to be used against regular
humans.
Oh god, the zombies are going to keep evolving too.
Well, it's pretty powerful as it is.
We'll need to keep upgrading it to defeat the zombies.
I hope...
My hope for this game is that there's like an endless mode
or something, you know?
Of the gameplay.
You know what, maybe I should just play Vampire Survivor.
Even though I've never played it before.
There is?
Oh!
Let's go.
Hey, Kanon-chan.
Uh-oh,
Nagisa's thinking too hard.
These zombies used to be normal people, right?
Uh-oh, don't think about it!
Nagisa, don't think about it!
Oh.
Uh, more.
Well, yes.
Turn off the brain!
It just makes me a bit uneasy to think about killing someone
like that.
Hollow Cure!
I've never played Hollow Cure either.
But I've seen so many people, like, really enjoying it, so
maybe I'll play that, too.
Actually, that's a lie.
I think.
It's a lie.
Play as Takanashi Kiara.
Maoshi.
K is goaded.
That guy.
He's crazy.
Happy I could catch a live stream.
Thank you!
I mean, they could be my friends or former co-workers, you
know?
A weak mindset like that is going to get you killed.
Hanya was your Oshi.
Hanya was my Oshi too.
You can have more than one Oshi.
Hanya is my Kamiyoshi.
It's different.
She has a rookie eyes.
Her own those that have become zombies lose all sense of
perception and judgment.
become as corpses capable of movement.
Their brains have been invaded and destroyed.
The only thing remaining is their will to attack humans.
Yeah, I'm fine if I become infected.
It's not always going to happen to us.
If I've been bitten, Oh, we don't know for sure if you're
completely immune.
One too many bites and you might become one of them for all
I know.
Also she is really brave.
Just standing in the street.
I was gifted a sub.
Welcome!
Besides, I doubt you want to try getting minced by zombie
teeth to test out that theory, Yeah.
Yeah.
I think I'll pass.
Thank you!
Thank you, I'm right.
For real?
Really?
You mean that?
Miss Nagisa, may I remind you?
Those that have fully transformed won't be able to be saved.
It's impossible no matter how good it is.
the vaccine may end up being oh my gosh we're gonna have to
cut off rinka's arm
oh they're just human shaped that's all please don't hold
back on shooting them for your sake as well if we were
bitten by mint what would we become i don't think you'd
become I'm a ghost.
I can scratch you guys.
I could scratch your backs.
Sometimes people don't like that, though.
They're just like, I was scratched by a ghost.
And it left a mark on my back.
Happens all the time in, like, those ghost shows.
All I'm trying to do is, like, scratch your...
You scratch my back, I scratch yours.
No matter who you may end up facing.
You can now purchase metal!
Oh my gosh, this is so cute!
The space is a safe zone.
You can prepare for battle here.
Deployment, you can set your deployment units along with
location.
You can purchase items, oh my gosh, there's so much going
on.
Mint fight equals brain freeze.
Purchase items and power them up here.
Treatment.
You can treat any zombified maids.
I want your scratches to turn people into maids.
Do you want to become a maid?
Maid world takeover.
Oh!
Dinka.
You can treat any zombified maids.
Select the maids that you want to treat after choosing this
option.
Substories.
Unlocked when certain conditions are met.
Save load.
Auto saving the gate or auto saves after battle or any
events.
These saves cannot be overwritten, but you may load from
previous saves.
The pressing Y will make a cursor appear which we can use to
touch the base!
Wait, it's not Y on the keyboard.
What is it?
Oh, uh, touch Q.
So where is it?
Madoche is so cute.
Nade, nade!
So cute!
Let's see.
What's under workshop?
Q.
Oh, I can't touch them here.
buy items what do we got oh we could just buy the magazine
you can buy various items at the points that were earned in
battle this includes materials necessary for crafting
there's crafting in this game even oh my gosh some materials
are able to be purchased others can only be obtained through
combat holy cow had pat the bottom right man no an opi lap
pot Selection of items will be limited early on, but will
increase based on number of areas cleared.
Additionally, some items will only appear when certain maids
are deployed.
Ninka!
This is spoilers.
Is it not?
Disposables can be selected to take it to battle.
Disposable?
She's not disposable?
Ninka!
The effects of an item will last throughout the battle, but
will disappear when returning to base.
You can only bring one disposable.
Accessories are compatible with any maid of your choice.
consider which accessories should be equipped with which
maid depending on the situation gosh there's so much to this
game we can get metal let's buy one metal i don't know what
it'll do the apocalypse doesn't look bad at all yeah
powering up equipment will strength will strengthen each
maid And accessories may close range weapons and shooting
weapons need the right materials to power up.
Is she also in the title screen?
Shh, shh, shh.
Oh yeah, how did I, oh, it was right button for close combat
stuff.
CQC.
Shooting weapons grant different bonuses based on the
equipped maid.
Select a maid and choose a stat you want to increase.
By doing this, you can check what statuses can be increased.
Holy cow, this is so...
and the results will be displayed during confirmation whilst
you need all required materials to power up items if those
missing materials are purchasable the purchase can be made
on the spot to provide or proceed with powering up each made
brings a unique sniper rifle strength to the team make sure
to not only not focus solely on increasing the strength of
one but to train a handful equally to counter any situation
accessories are the one selection that could be changed
during deployment by Choosing change accessory, choose the
accessory you want to switch to from the accessory list.
Accessories cannot be powered up unless equipped.
Power up results and also enhance skills used in battle.
So what else can we get?
Combat knife?
Oh, one metal!
Wait, what about our rifle, though?
Oh, oh, let's do the metal, or the rifle.
What's our accessory?
Boo-boop.
Sometimes Wonder of Mint is actually the ghost of an
oji-san.
What?
No.
What's my inventory?
Bullets and metal.
Wait, a special bullet that can be used to befriend zombies?
Only works on made-like zombies.
How convenient.
Wait.
Hold on.
Can I upgrade my weapon again?
Oh, I don't know.
have enough money okay oh look my bad
let's go strike
vdx ready clear conditions none okay only five more minutes
okay i don't know what that means me fighting Oji-san!
You can select your deployed units along with the location.
When selecting a location, you must select an area first and
choose a stage.
The condition needed to clear the stage will be displayed.
Take note that each stage has different conditions.
All right.
And required.
Playable characters are limited to maids that can be
deployed.
You cannot deploy any zombified maids.
Each maid has different weapons that they are able to equip.
Additionally, they all have distinct skills and special
skills.
disposable state.
What is the disposable?
Okay.
Red breath.
What does that mean?
Let's go.
Assist bullets.
You can fire bullets by holding down RT.
You can recruit any made zombies from across enemy lines by
shooting.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, any!
Wait, RT.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Uh, maybe I should be playing this with a controller.
Wait, now I'm not sure at all.
Uh, these tutorials are super long-winded.
Uh, but what do I hold down?
Now, now I'm using my controller.
Wait, now I don't know how to do anything.
Wait, I think...
Wait, uh-oh.
Control the...
Check the control mapping.
Yeah, yeah.
So B or RT.
These will not work on giant zombies.
Assist bullets pierce through the enemy other than made
zombies.
And will hit any enemy within range.
Amount of bullets that can be brought into battle are
limited.
Purchasing new bullets will replenish any used prior.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, and then they come and join.
If they take too much damage, they will retreat.
Oh, that's so cute.
You can have multiple allied maids.
Nine maximum.
Recruiting more maids will result in more potential
strategies in battle and strengthen your army.
Wait, I'm actually making a maid, are we?
MSF.
Maids, sounds, frontiers.
I'll be having a fun stream.
It was my birthday yesterday, so can I...
Now justify my hip hurting sometimes.
I'm getting dizzy when I get up too fast.
It's normal for 20.
Oh my god, babies.
I don't know about you.
I'm feeling 20, too.
But, um, yeah, as, uh, as, uh, oh, someone else said, you
should probably go see a doctor.
Happy birthday!
Okay, why is the unique skill?
Special skill gauge.
Okay, I see it.
Alright.
Alright, alright.
Oh, wait.
I kind of, oh gosh, I kind of hate.
Oh, God, the aiming on the controller is awful!
Oh, God!
Oh, God.
Okay, wait.
Okay, I'm gonna use...
Oh no, I can't do both.
I can't... Oh god, oh god.
It's so bad.
Okay, you know what?
Back to...
Drone!
I'm gonna have to check the, uh, what's it called?
Magnetic field.
Oh wait!
Lightning drone!
What?
Ooh, trying to collect more hearts.
Combat, Jira- oh, I- oh no, the speed!
Okay, next time we'll- next time we get speed, you guys.
We're gonna get more speed.
Where's some- where's some- some little maids?
Okay, hold on.
Let's do options.
And- Well, I guess we'll just, um, figure it out.
I guess we'll just figure it out.
Interface spoilers.
Nah, I'm not concerned.
I wasn't even looking.
Don't worry.
Oh my god, there's so many here.
What is it?
More drones.
Oh.
Optimize is pretty good too though.
I probably should grab that.
I don't know how many, actually how many skills I can get,
you know?
Oh, there's so much over here.
Come on, guys.
Let's blow them up.
There's so much hearts here.
Made?
Oh, wait.
You guys, I learned how to do my special attack.
I learned how to do my specials
We got another drown
Oh man Oh wait what's this I'm so Okay but then what could
Oh
Sensor Let's try it Is this like it pulls items closer to
me?
Or like I can collect items more easily, you know?
What could it be?
Okay, so is that maybe like Z or X will be it?
I'll try Z or X next time we see a maid.
Oh!
Maid!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay.
More drone.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
No, don't shoot her, don't shoot!
Don't shoot, don't shoot!
My drones!
Drones!
What are you doing?
She's mine!
Uh, Z...
Oh, she's dead.
Wait, Z or X does not work.
No!
Stop killing her!
I need to practice on her!
Um...
E or R?
E!
Oh.
I didn't get the... I didn't get to press it.
I didn't get to press it.
Try right-click.
That's what did my special attack.
It was Z or X for me, but you have to hold it down for
several seconds.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I see her.
I see her.
Z!
ZX!
There it is.
Oh.
It went just straight past her.
Was that a big man?
That counted as a big man.
Oh.
Let's just keep increasing their strength.
Wait, they're gonna kill all the maids.
She was weak.
I'll take whatever that is.
Let's see.
More drone!
My drones are everywhere.
They're circling me everywhere.
It's a lot of drones.
Yeah, you know.
We just gotta survive, right?
For five minutes.
We're so slow.
Please give us speed.
Please give us a speed power-up.
I need a maid.
Okay, so I think it was X actually that it worked on, so as
soon as I see a girly...
Look at all these convenience workers.
It's so sad.
Speed?
Magnetic field.
That sounds fun.
Ooh!
More toilet paper.
You're gonna need toilet paper if you want to survive the
apocalypse, you know?
I know my special bullets limited.
And I wasted it.
I didn't realize she was a big mate.
I want to just be faster.
I know we're in, like, the early stages and everything.
Oh!
Yo!
As the rank.
Hmm.
Yoshi!
Anton!
Hot dog!
I can now purchase Titan Silver.
And F- Fiber!
Fiber Wipe up!
Got a final tomorrow.
Can't stay.
Sorry.
No worries!
What's the clear conditions on this one?
Defeat all enemies.
We can do that.
Easy peasy.
Strike.
Let's just go.
We can do that easy.
Oh.
Pause.
Yeah.
During a pause menu, you can switch between two screens.
Status, radar, for in-range weapons.
Oh, look at that.
It tells you everything.
We can watch the events after a battle.
We need to level up.
We need to power up, power up.
Temporary invisibility.
Vaccine materials for bullets.
Distribute points after battle.
Flamethrower.
Change the... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cool.
Gotta defeat all the enemies!
Oh, look at these guys.
Nice.
Let's do...
Let's do the magnetic field again.
Brrrr!
Hey, give me more hearts.
Give me more hearts.
Maid!
We can actually get her on our side, maybe.
Speed!
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I'm in trouble.
Ah, let's see.
I'll see.
I took some damage, but that's okay.
She's on our side!
Yippee!
We have a maid now.
How many enemies are there?
Oh, she's attacking?
She's...
Oh god.
Uh...
Ah!
I wish I had a drone.
Oh, perfect timing!
Welcome to the army.
Welcome to the main army.
Nice.
More drone!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I don't know what's going on.
More drones!
Oh, increase the strength on my thing.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, well.
Oh my gosh, maid girls, be careful!
Be careful!
I'm clearing a path!
They follow, which is pretty cute.
Oh, is my stream buffering?
Ah, no!
I wasted my...
Is my stream buffering?
Oh, I'll go.
Okay.
Sorry if there's some weird...
It's fine.
Sorry if there's some weird YouTube stuff going on.
I don't know.
Auto heals.
Sounds kind of nice.
I wonder how it auto heals.
Let's try it.
We should probably start experimenting with more things, you
know?
Oh, gosh.
There you go, everybody.
Oh, vaccine.
This one.
Nice.
Niceu.
I still don't know how to slash.
I still don't know how to do the close range combat.
I can get all up in the zombies' face and deal damage to
them, so don't worry about distance.
Yeah, I know.
I know that's what it does.
Guys, stop backseating me!
Mod?
What the hell?
Middle click?
Oh, let me try middle click.
Let's see.
Oh, uh...
Hmm.
Magnetic field 4?
Oh, it increases the range.
Or one more droid.
Let's increase the range.
No, middle click isn't doing anything.
It's a big girl.
Oh!
How could Mint forget the basics of CQC?
I'm honestly... How am I supposed to defeat all of these?
Yes!
More drones.
I wish I could get more maids as well.
We're close to being...
We're close to being able to use our attack or special.
Okay.
Just use our special.
There it is.
Oh, there's more falling from the sky!
Somebody dropped their toilet paper.
More drought.
More movement.
Oh, my God.
Speed.
Thank God.
40%?
Hell yeah.
Okay.
Alright, they're starting to dwindle a little bit.
We're doing well.
Max.
Just max this guy out, you know?
Oh, the Otaku!
You were like a death ball.
I know, it's awesome, right?
How many more guys are there?
I say...
More drones!
Ah, yeah!
Hello, drones.
More maids!
I haven't seen any other girl, any other maid girls.
I haven't seen any We haven't tried the grenade Let's try
stuff like this, you know We haven't tried anything like
this Do I just throw them out?
Oh, I throw them out Okay, perfect I don't have to like
select it or anything Cool Oh, watch out for the fire
Oh my god, I am so powerful Look at this
Increases drones.
Oh my god!
Oh, thank god I'm a little ball of death, right?
They ambushed me like that!
Oh, my health did heal!
That's so awesome.
Your own fire is probably safe?
I guess we'll see.
Land mine.
Plant a bomb on...
You know what?
Let's try it.
We have still quite a few...
few amount of skill points.
Let's go test my fire.
Oh, okay, it's gone.
Wee!
Oh, this is the bomb.
I'm planting bombs.
Get her!
No damage.
Yeah, nice.
Drone maids.
Yes.
Yippee!
More speed!
Okay, how are you doing my little maids?
Oh gosh.
Whoa Don't get hurt.
Don't get hurt Oh god, oh god.
Oh, I don't have my skill.
Oh my god.
Oh my god My skill is not let's see um More drone strength
Luckily the landmines like kind of oh my god The maids,
like, kind of get in my way.
I'm not going to lie.
They make it, they, like, push me.
I have to, like, push through them, you know?
Don't let the maids die.
Oh, more drones.
Perfect.
Perfection.
I know what can solve any horrible situation.
Oh, my God.
Stop landing on me.
I don't know what my HP is at.
But it does heal by itself.
Oh, my gosh.
Little maids.
I need you to move.
Maids.
Wait, please.
Let's do more heat.
I want the toilet paper.
Oh, no!
Oh, wow!
Oh, no, we lost one.
We lost a maid.
Your maid army is to die for.
We lost a maid, you guys.
Probably should do my...
Holy cow.
cow.
Yippee!
She went out as a human.
So true.
It's not that they run away.
I think she's alright.
You can't convert the big maids?
No, you can't.
Only the small maids.
That one was fine.
Let's see what we can upgrade now.
Or rather, can we buy anything?
Okay.
Look at me, boy.
Oh, yeah, this is the special.
Oh, we only have one left, so...
Oh, they're cheap.
They're really cheap.
Oh, I can only buy two.
Okay.
I need vaccines to make the bullets.
Okay, understandable, understandable.
Okay.
I have four of those.
No.
Five, six.
Okay.
Let's upgrade some stuff.
Let's upgrade our rifle.
Okay.
Yes.
Nice.
What about my mid out there?
Oh, Fiverr!
Upgrade.
How much money do I have?
Where is my money?
Uh...
Anyway, let's just spend it all.
I don't know where my money is.
Fiverr, Wipea.
My speed went up?
No way.
Oh, it does.
It increases your defense speed and HP.
Let's do it again then.
Where's my money?
How much money do I have?
6,000.
Wait, how do you guys see it?
Oh, I see.
MP is possession.
We are going to be so strong.
I would upgrade my combat knife more, but like, I don't know
how to use it, so.
Producer sign, pretty much.
Okay, that should be good.
I think for now.
What's the clear conditions?
Defeat the boss!
Don't forget to save.
Oh, it auto saves, though, right?
If you don't look at your money, it's like you're not
spending it.
I do that all the time.
all right let's go let's go try strike
yeah it auto saves oh
have you found any signs of miss linka's whereabouts No,
not yet.
I don't even know where I should be looking.
Yeah.
I thought so.
Akihabura isn't really that big, but searching while having
to fight off zombies is no easy task.
I mean, I've been like in the same street.
An imposter.
Of the boss.
No matter what I find her, I've made up my mind that I'll be
the one to save her.
It's funny, isn't it?
Why are you so dead set on finding Miss Rinka?
You think it's weird?
Isn't it normal to want to save a friend?
It'll mean risking your own life, though.
the logic of wanting to do that when she isn't even a family
member.
Are you saying you have to have some kind of reason before
you save someone?
Oh, it's not.
That's not it.
I'm asking you if this reason of yours is worth putting your
life on the line for.
Friend.
The reason I put myself in danger, huh?
I mean, I didn't really think much of it, wait, think of it
too much, but it's because she's my friend.
You didn't answer my question.
I'm not lying, though.
Rinka is the same age as me, but she started working at the
maid cafe before I did.
That must be the cafe that we're using as a base right now.
She's got them crazy eyes again.
And on my first shift, she ended up being the one to teach
me the ropes.
I thought she was reserved and a little scary in the
beginning, but she'd always come to my rescue when I missed
all.
I'm not sure, but I'm private, even though I'm playing with
her.
We went to different universities, but we'd always hang out
when we could, and before I realized it, we were We're
always together.
A best friend of sorts.
Is that it?
You could say that.
Oh.
When we were handing out flyers, some people that had turned
into zombies started attacking us.
John did a plot twist.
I was frozen in place with everything that was going on, but
Rinka saved me from the zombies.
I like the music in this game a lot.
Hold on, I'm gonna get a cough drop real quick.
I have one.
I got one.
Give me one second.
To put it in.
Thinking back, that must have been the moment that she was
bitten and got infected by the virus.
Very like-minded.
Did you say something?
No.
If we wanted to, if we were in the UDX area, it's It's more
like this direction, behind you guys, behind chat.
It's nothing.
Anyway, in regards to searching for Mr. Ninka, that building
over there seems to be a gathering spot for the zombies.
They nailed the sentimental guitar tone.
Yeah, it's really nice.
And then also, just like, all the soundtrack for this is
really good.
Like the rocking parts too.
I don't know.
They haven't left the area where you and Miss Minko split,
which means there might be some sort of clue around them.
Then I need to get a move on!
Oh, indoor zombie.
Please do your best to be careful.
Battling zombies indoors is going to be much more of a
challenge than usual.
Well,
make sure to be extra careful then.
Don't worry about it.
Plus, you'll save me if I need it, right?
Seeing as I won't be there for you, you might have a hard
time calling me for help.
Silly me!
I'm gonna beat those zombies for Ninka's sake.
Oh my god, she's zoomed off.
I don't think Kanon has any My friend.
Right.
For your friend.
We're gonna need a miracle.
Oh my god!
Give me hearts!
Drown!
Give me more hearts.
Give me hearts.
You guys want brains.
I want hearts.
Oh, nice.
I always want more.
Give me more drones.
I changed my mind.
More drones.
This song!
Oh.
I don't know what I just heard, but...
I don't know what that just implied, but...
Oh gosh.
There's even, like, this wall here.
Okay.
Let's also do the grenade.
I think this can be pretty...
A good passive.
Oh, okay, so...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
You guys, we're about to get...
Oh gosh, okay.
Well, I think that was my skill that I heard.
Being good.
Okay.
I thought we were about to get...
What's to learn?
Trapped?
More drone!
Let's do more drone.
Yoshi!
a dog oh my god you guys
i'm terrible no it's just dog shaped it's not a dog it's
just dog shaped you guys it's dog shaped it's not real it's
not real it's not real it's not real it's not real it's not
real it's not real it's not real okay can you stop throwing
the grenades like in useless places thank you oh my god just
ignore him just ignore that oh my god the drones take care
of him i have no guilt i have no guilt magnetic field
he's just a boy he looks kind of aggressive though
let's do the auto heal as well it's pretty good to have nice
oh oh Oh, oh.
Nice.
Okay.
Having at least two maids on our side is pretty good, I'd
say.
All right, girls.
Let's fight.
Heaven or hell.
You're going somewhere to not.
Hello, I'm so late.
Hello!
All you missed was...
There's a zombie apocalypse, and we fight in Akihabara as a
maid.
Nice.
I love drones.
Does it feel like...
It doesn't really feel like we're that much faster, I'll be
honest.
Let's see.
Oh, the optimized...
Oh shoot.
I should have grabbed that.
I'll get it when it comes back around.
Where's the boss?
Where's the boss after all?
Drones are the future.
Hmm.
The song's on rotation.
Let's see.
Hmm.
Um...
Oh, this is the max.
I'll do the max.
Oh, what's that?
Ooh.
Oh, I think that's the thing that helps us get more...
Uh, stuff for...
Leveling up for skills.
Oh, I just realized the normal grenade.
We've been using the fire grenade.
I like the fire grenade, though.
Guys, we're at max dronage.
We're at max dronage, I believe.
Um...
Oh, never mind.
We can always have more drones.
Oh, gosh!
I just noticed their shadows as they came down on me.
No!
Die somebody!
everybody must die oh my god oh holy moly uh oh my gosh oh
god girlies girlies move out move out girlies move out move
out I gotta be more the shadows show up and like they drop
down so quickly see oh there it is Watch out, watch out,
watch out!
I got you, I got you!
Oh, more, more, more!
Hmm.
We can do more power.
Holy cow.
Watch out!
Strength.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god, watch out, girls!
Watch out!
We gotta get out of this corner.
Ooh!
Come on!
Keep walking!
Yeah, they're all getting taken out.
Just do a tackle down.
The faster we can attack, the better.
And my health is healing.
It's auto-heal, so it's not bad at all.
These guys are all going...
Holy cow!
There's so many of them!
Oops.
There's so many of them.
Just drop the...
Oh!
Uh-oh.
What's going on?
I hear footsteps.
Oh my god, there's blood everywhere.
I missed the giant, I missed the treasure!
Oh well.
I didn't realize how dark it'd be in here without the lights
on.
If I don't pay close attention, I might trip and fall over
something.
Oh, what was that?
Oh.
Biting makes me feel good.
Oh no!
You're a zombie!
Miss Nagisa, on your right is some shattered glass.
You'll be fine with those shoes, but please be wary.
How's you know about the glass, Ganon?
You can't see what's going on, can you?
The codec.
There's a miniature camera and the communication device.
I can switch it to night vision mode.
So everything is crystal clear to me.
I love her outfit.
Oh my gosh.
Combat maids.
So awesome.
Wait.
Her uniform is kind of similar to mine, isn't it?
With like the...
With her collar and then my collar and then...
Mine, the only difference is mine is off the shoulder
sleeves.
How funny.
Technology sure is impressive these days.
However, using the camera will run down the battery, so I
won't be using it for long.
All you need is an assault rifle.
So true.
It's pretty small, so the battery isn't anything special.
Sending video through, constantly will drain it quickly.
Yeah, it's like I'm a maid or something.
Crazy.
I guess even this has a weakness.
I can't tell if it's useful or not when you say it like
that.
I guess it's just a case.
It's just a machine at the end of the day, so relying on it
too much wouldn't be wise.
Because of the pandemic, a lot of places are out of power.
Charging it could be troublesome.
Oh, oh, is that what we're doing?
Oh, to be frank, we're trying to take back this area from
the zombies, in order to gain access to a power generator.
Who is we?
You, Kanon?
I'm trying to find my friend.
You really are thinking this through, aren't you, Kanon?
We is you.
Me and you?
I didn't agree to this.
More battle made mint art ideas.
For vaccine, sorry if we could hear my chair popping.
Oh my goodness.
From vaccine-making to researching the virus, electricity is
going to be a major factor.
We'll have to consider.
Oh my god.
Am I going to become an electrician too?
Though it's been a while.
Before the pandemic, I used to have lunch around here often.
Oh!
Chair upgrade when...
When this chair truly can't sit my butt anymore.
You too, Kanon!
They used to come here before, actually.
Does that mean you used to work in Akihabara, too?
I think Kanon is the cause of the virus.
You there?
Nagisa, son, you get there!
What was it?
That seems like it, but for one to have that sort of
agility.
I didn't know that this bait cafe made you have a
color-coded you know panties too Zambi oh my gosh look at
her wow oh my gosh wait twins you have the same garter belt
even
so classy.
Oh my god.
Rinka's the boss.
Same underwear, too.
I'm not showing you that.
That's her?
We?
Who is we?
There is no we.
We find them.
It's me, Nagisa!
Oh, Rinka is already starting to transform.
I think she, I mean, yeah?
We painted some of this screenshot green.
Yay, yay, yay, yay.
But she isn't attacking.
Oh.
Oh my god, speak up, Kanon.
I can't hear you over this sick rift.
Zombies should automatically start attacking any humans they
can see.
Could she have heard Miss Nagisa's voice and stopped
attacking?
No.
A virus at this level would block out anything like that.
Oh, sorry.
Rift.
This rift in my heart.
This too is Yori.
Nice rift.
Oh my god.
What should I do?
How do I save her?
Oh my god.
If Miss Rinka is still aware, then her brain must not have
been fully infected yet.
Oh my god.
Kiss her.
In other words, she's only a partial zombie.
Her body must be fighting the virus as we speak.
That means if we jab her with the vaccine, she'll go back to
normal, right?
There's a chance, but her condition is getting worse and
she's losing awareness by the minute.
Okay, let's...
Yapping then.
Holding her down and bringing her back to base like that is
going to be risky.
If there's even a sliver of a chance, I want to take it.
Hold her down, hold her down!
I'll be preparing the vaccine as planned.
Dang, Kanon is so fast.
The zombie apocalypse just happened like today.
and she's already got a vaccine.
Wow.
Should have put her in charge of the 2020 pandemic.
Also, if we can get samples from someone else who didn't
immediately transform, that also helped my research.
But understood.
Understand that We're the only one that can stop Miss Dinka
and bring her back here.
Let's shoot her!
Don't worry, Dinka!
We'll save you no matter what!
She's like...
Oh shoot!
Oh god!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god!
Way to put me back mid-battle!
Oh my god.
Watch out, girls!
Don't take any more damage like that.
You're scaring me.
Oh my god.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
More vaccine stuff.
How are my maids doing?
Uh, where are my maids?
Oh, there's one left.
Yeah!
Gosh, I'm gonna get cornered here.
I'm gonna get cornered here.
Oh no!
Oh, I think we got...
I can't see myself, I have so many drones.
I had too many drones, you couldn't even see my little
sprite.
Yay!
Superbar is full, but you didn't even need it.
Yeah, we were all good.
After the battle with Rinka ended, I carried her back to
base because she was too exhausted to move.
I think it's supposed to say it was just as Kanon had said.
Rinka's body was in the process of transforming.
If everything goes well, then she'll return to normal.
But if she doesn't, I don't know what I'll do.
Fire the cannon, Kano.
Wait, why is there?
Nagisa, sir, the treatment of the treatment is done.
If it goes well, then she'll return to normal.
Why does this exist in the Maid Cafe?
Miss Nagisa.
Everything is ready.
Oh yeah, sometimes they put two ends for Kanon and sometimes
just one.
But it's okay.
We're not here so much for the translation, right?
If it goes well, then we'll be able to fix Miss Rinka just
as planned.
But if the vaccine doesn't work as intended,
So, please.
go through with it.
Roll playroom?
Probably.
This is probably the maid cafe next door.
It's hospital themed.
You have to lay in your bed and eat your food that way.
I guess I don't need to say any more.
Well then, let us begin the procedure.
Saving.
I don't think we need to save her at all.
I don't think this is...
We don't need to save her at all.
What are you talking about?
Let her stay, please!
Oh my god, no.
No, please.
Don't make me do this.
She's perfect.
She's perfect the way she is.
Oh my god.
The teeth.
eyes!
The skin!
Ah!
You can fix her.
She's already...
This is an improvement.
She's already fixed.
Why is the music so loud?
You can treat any zombified maids.
Maids will become zombified if you defeat them as enemies
and take them back to base.
Or if they are defeated in battle after deployment.
Oh my god.
Oh!
She's so cute!
So
Dombified maids cannot be deployed.
Make sure to treat them immediately.
Furthermore, if all of your maids have been zombified, it
will result in a game over.
Game, please.
Game.
To heal, you need a vaccine.
If you run out, you can purchase them in the item shop.
Oh, by shaking vaccine bottles.
You can max out their shake gauge.
What's full treatment will be applied to the target?
I don't think that's...
What kind of vaccine is this?
Oh!
Hey, no spoilers!
By spreading the vaccine, the patient will slowly heal.
Make sure to spread it around and up until they are fully
recovered.
Why is it a topical vaccine?
I could fix her.
I just don't want to.
Mason, I've already completed their treatment, can skip this
option during the base treatment selection.
I'm shaking it.
Shoko, Shoko, Shoko.
I'm sorry that I must cure you.
I'm sorry.
This is... I'm...
You were perfect the way you were, Dinka.
I could... I would... I would take you as you were.
Okay, using medicine, go!
The color is returning to her eyes!
Shoko, Shoko, Shoko, Shoko, Shoko, Shoko.
I love life, Shoko.
Shoko, Shoko.
Chico, chico, chico, chico.
You guys, it's medicine.
This is for medicinal purposes.
I walked all the way away for 30 minutes.
Yeah.
She looks concerned.
I mean, she was a zombie.
Don't worry about it.
I'm just jorking it in the hospital real quick.
And by it, I mean my medicine.
Again?
More?
I think she's okay.
Oh, no.
Let's keep going.
Oh, never mind.
Success!
Stop it, Shinji.
That's what, yeah, Shinji was doing maybe.
Oh, you're still here?
I think we all should have assumed that it would be a
topical medicine.
I'm jerking my medicine right now too I don't know I don't
know what You know what you're being healthy Everybody Jork
your medicine Take your vitamins okay I want it to be with
Vinka We don't know when to wake up you know I'm so messed
up I'm so messed up I understand how you feel, but you must
be exhausted as well.
Don't forget that you need to rest, too.
Take your meds.
I can't afford to rest now.
If Inka wakes up and she's not healed, I'll have to fight
again.
And you made fun of me for making a joke and a joke.
oh my gosh angel and cesarean miss your very spookiest dono
earlier finally back from the u.s and can enjoy my kamiyoshi
live again without having grass to touch or some or some
such just so you know this trip never would have happened if
it wasn't for you so thank you what
i did nothing thank you
if it comes to that then you'll be in danger besides every
time I close my eyes all I see is unpleasant memories of the
medicine every time I close my eyes I imagine the medicines
but if miss Ninka doesn't revert back I'm pretty sure it
worked I'm just saying boys we know how to stop the
apocalypse do you have the antibodies do you have the
antibodies to stop the apocalypse I
I know it needs to be done.
But I believe that it won't come to that.
Rinca is strong.
She'll definitely recover.
Only one way to find out.
You could be one in a million.
I'll be continuing my efforts and refining the vaccine.
I think it works perfectly fine.
So please keep an eye on Mission Rinca.
Animes.
She's awake.
She needs a shower probably.
Never mind.
Oh, it all absorbed into her skin.
Wow.
Where am I?
Oh!
Yeah, the underwear is color-coded.
It is, it is.
Nakisa, why are you... I remember getting bit by a zombie
and...
You forgot what happened?
I can't wait until we get our next girl.
I don't know.
I remember we split up, but everything after that is hazy.
Just a reminder, Kanon made the vaccine and decided it
should be a topical.
Yeah, I think we should infect Rinca again, I'm just saying.
It seems like your memories from after you were bitten have
been affected.
Do you feel sick or dizzy perhaps?
I mean, look at this CG.
It's so cute.
Look at them.
You're...
Who are you?
Let's see the formalities for later.
Our first priority is to check you over and see how you're
doing.
Oh no, I've been dead!
I have the vaccine.
Shuku-shu-shu-shu-shu-shu-shu-shu-shu-shu- may have some
lingering effects from the virus so it's important to do a
thorough check the virus huh
why aren't her clothes destroyed here cowards
i see you were the one that made the vaccine thank you so
much i wouldn't be here without you All I did was make it.
The one that saved you was Miss Nagisa.
Vaccine fixed the clothes, too?
Not in the CG!
Even after being attacked by zombies, she never gave up.
She was determined to save you.
Nagisa...
Nagisa, you risked your life for me?
Are you mad, Rinka?
Why would she be mad?
A little?
Of course I'm great.
Oh, a little.
Of course I'm grateful that you saved me, but you put
yourself in so much danger.
Says the person who's always trying to play it cool and save
others.
You sacrificed your own safety for my sake too.
Oh my god, Herman.
I wanted to save you.
So that's what I did.
Now we're even, okay?
Rinka's face.
Rinka's so cute.
All of them are very cute.
Q-Rate was always really good at making very cute girls.
Fine, let's just leave it at that.
I would have done the same thing if I were you.
Now that you have two mates, you'll be able to apply twice
as much vaccine to the next girl.
I can hear you, you know.
Okay,
you too.
Let it be for now.
Mizorinka just woke up, so she'll need a bit more rest.
Did curate make me in?
No.
They didn't.
Sounds like a good idea.
Thanks, Kanon.
You're the reason we could save Rinka, Nian.
No, Nagisa-san got Rinka, Nian.
No.
Honestly, to be honest, Rinka-san was able to save her
because you believed in her.
Make you lose your nose.
What are you talking about?
We were able to save her because you believed in her.
To be honest, this is nothing short of a miracle.
But this wasn't thanks to the vaccine?
I mean, yes, it was.
What?
What are you talking about?
It worked?
We still don't know exactly how effective it is.
And to be honest, I didn't think situations like Rinkas were
possible.
I'm so distracted when Kanon talks, there's like a little
part here that like, like the pixels like start going a
little wonky.
I wanted to make sure so I ran a couple of tests and it
seems Miss Rinca also carries an antibody that helped her
fight the infection just like you.
Wonder where she got that from.
The same as me, but that doesn't make sense.
I didn't transform at all.
Oh,
see it.
Nagisa, I'm not.
The antibodies don't completely block the virus, so it's
possible you might still transform if bitten enough.
What happens here too?
I see it now.
Don't scare me like that, Kanon!
...
But it's the truth.
So please don't forget it.
Those antibodies aren't perfect.
Though I'm glad we figured that out from this whole ordeal.
...
I know, it's kind of distracting.
Even if someone were to start having symptoms, it seems as
though the antibodies slowed down the entire process.
Starting to think this game may not be scientifically
accurate.
No.
They've consulted so many doctors for this game, I think.
If we act fast during that phase, we may be able to stop the
zombification.
This is useful information to have.
I want to zombify.
Oh, I can't wait to find our next zombified girl.
Give it to me.
Then if we can make enough vaccines, everyone would have the
antibody, right?
That'd make the virus a lot easier to deal with.
NAPMAS!
Let's welcome the membership.
Thank you!
Maybe the key to ending this pandemic.
What if, yeah, what if we zombify Nagisa?
Will it work if she gets caught?
If she like...
The nice girl's gonna make me happy.
Though we still need more samples from others with the
antibody to make a stronger vaccine.
Rinka and I won't be enough?
No.
Just gonna drain your body of blood.
I hope they're maids.
It's always better to have more samples.
So we'll have to search for more survivors that are
potential carriers.
It's the maids genes!
The maids genes!
That sounds like something I can do.
We just have to find survivors and protect them, right?
Zombie canon.
You're fine with doing that?
I thought your goal had already been achieved.
I don't know why you'd want to danger your own life further.
I mean, it may, think about it.
You guys can't stay cramped in this little maid cafe.
You have to, you know?
You know?
You know, Kanon-chan, you know?
We were able to save Dinka because of your efforts.
So if we can make a stronger vaccine, more people will end
up being saved, right?
But that's the case, then of course, I have to help.
Just let me know what to do.
Someone needs to go get the toilet paper.
Exactly.
Don't you mind?
Don't you mostly stay cramped in a make-up- shut up!
I'm haunting!
It's different!
That sounds just like you, Miss Nagisa.
In that case, I'll leave it up to you.
We should start by taking back some of the areas overrun
with zombies and creating safe zones.
And then we'll investigate those said areas.
I'm getting pumped!
I'll do my best!
Yeah!
Ugh.
My throat is starting to hurt.
What the?
That was so fast.
Is it true you found survivors, Kanon?
I was able to confirm that someone had shot off some
fireworks.
That was the fastest she like, she just like stepped out for
two seconds.
Fireworks?
It could be that someone was trying to call out for help
with them.
They're probably in need of fire.
food or water or something.
Okay, we gotta go get the new girl.
I can't wait to see her, I can't wait to see her, I can't
wait to see her, I can't wait to see her.
I can't wait to see her.
Wouldn't that be dangerous though?
I mean, don't you think the zombies would notice it?
I'm sure it was a last resort of the sorts.
They must be desperate for help.
We have to save them as quick as I can!
They might be getting attacked by zombies right this second!
Desi-Zooshan, homo is the most important one.
Desi- Desi- Desi-Prette.
Sorry, I didn't even notice it.
Desi-Prette.
You're getting Desi-Prette, everybody.
The other survival?
The other survival might be our biggest priority right now.
possibly be carrying the antibody we need.
You're the only one that can do this, Miss Nagisa.
If Kanon was in charge of carrying the Big C, it would have
been over in two months.
That's what I'm saying!
We all need a Kanon.
We need a Kanon in this world.
You're the only one that can do this, Miss Nagisa.
Are there any objections?
Any objections?
Equips the gun.
puts on her crazy face.
None at all!
I'd really appreciate it if you could provide backup on the
communicator again.
Wait a minute.
Are you sure it's okay for you to be up and moving already?
Oh, I feel fine.
In fact, I feel lighter than ever if I'm being honest.
No.
Nagisa, were you trying to do something risky all by
yourself again, weren't you?
You heard me?
Why is the music so ominous?
I wasn't trying to listen in, but your voice was just as
loud as ever.
Please don't do anything reckless by yourself.
Okay, then come with me.
But I'm the only one that can fight the zombies, and there
might be others out there that I can save.
Oh, that's why I was thinking.
I'll go along with you.
How'd you get that gun?
It's too cool, I know, right?
I love the katana too.
The weaponry should have been locked.
Oh.
She picked the lock.
The security isn't all that tight.
I just played around with the lock a little and voila!
But with this, I can fight against them too.
And my body is like Nagisa's, right?
I was infected too, after all.
Why was there...
Where did she... Okay, but where did Kanon get all these
weapons?
And just stored them here.
who even read my science reports.
They're a lot more cunning than your look.
I'll take that as a compliment.
Made powers.
Stop asking questions.
Okay, I'm sorry.
Are you seriously planning on fighting zombies?
That's the plan.
Or are you saying be in the way?
Not at all.
I feel better if I had you with me.
I just don't want to put you in danger.
My body is the same as yours now.
There's no need to worry about me.
Besides,
you're quite the clut, Nagisa.
I'd feel more nervous leaving you all alone.
Thank you, Mint.
I don't think I'm that much of a clut.
Do you think I'm that much of a clut?
Oh.
Do you remember how many plates you broke at the cafe?
You even squirted ketchup in a customer's face by accident.
Not to mention.
You don't need to say all that in front of Kanon!
Sorry, I got a little carried away.
Yeah, let's go.
I'm ready to play the game.
Let's get going.
There's people out there that need our help.
Add her to the little menu.
You can now deploy.
Hairpin.
Substory, nice.
Hold on, before we do this.
She gets so angry.
Sorry, sorry.
Okay.
Let's go to the workshop.
and uh upgrade stuff so how do i change oh wait how do i
change now to oh there we go perfect so let's uh upgrade how
much how much money do i have oh eight thousand okay perfect
let's upgrade her a couple times oh we need more fiber
sniper rifle
Nice.
I don't remember what.
Hold on.
Four, five.
How can I get?
Change accessory.
Yeah, we have none.
Let's see if we can buy a thing.
We said we could buy a hairpin, right?
Whoa!
Accessory with a special arcana brand chip.
Increases power and point growth.
Ooh!
It's expensive.
How about?
20k.
Oh, here we go.
How much money did I have?
3,000?
Oh, thank you.
That should be good for now.
Yeah, we're going to have to save up.
We're going to have to save up, baby.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't wait till our maid cafe is full.
It's going to be so cute.
Okay, I'm excited.
Oh, gosh.
I can't wait to see who the next girl is.
Idol!
Idol?
Minto, Rinka got a PSG-1.
Hurry and save Mero.
Confirm deployment.
Yeah!
So I think this one is just survive for five minutes.
Wait, where is...
Where is she?
Oh my god.
They got...
The zombies have knives now.
Are these cosplayers?
Oh, I forgot to swap.
Oh!
I thought that they would both be able to come out at once.
Aw, man.
But it said that they were both required.
Speed.
Oh, this looks like the end of the map.
Nice.
Missile?
Oh my gosh, wait.
What was the miniature missile?
Look how cute the sprites are.
They're so cute.
What was that sound?
Oh, my special is ready.
Oh, this is a smaller map, actually.
We'll do the...
Oh, auto heal or magnetic field.
Let's do it.
Hmm.
Yasha!
Magnetic field!
La la la...
Yeah, I'm still slow.
I'm still so slow.
I like the incendiary garlic.
I like these ones, too.
Because they blow up and also leave a lasting, you know?
I think...
Oh!
Macium!
Nice.
Vacuum!
Let's do!
Oh, that's why, so they stay in place.
So that's why they kind of like, don't hang around me.
And sometimes there will be places that are filled with
hearts.
And I'm like, how?
Why?
Ura.
I'm trying to get these hearts in here.
Optimize.
Oh, when did I get this?
I want the missiles to come back.
What a waste.
Flamethrower.
So nice.
Oh, I think I saw some Otaku-chan!
Hello!
Oh, there's a main dude!
Oh.
Oh, they're coming out.
They're coming out.
Oh, there's a big girl.
There's a big girl.
Oh, I keep getting hurt.
Not bad.
I don't even know my own hitbox, I guess.
Don't get hurt!
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Yippee!
And I have my special if I need to use it.
I haven't forgotten.
Oh, what the hell?
What is my hitbox?
Grenade.
Sensor.
More drones!
I just noticed the friend.
Yeah, she's helping us out.
She's so cute.
Oh my god, there's so many otaku.
Otaku!
Oh, miniature missile!
Let's see how this works.
I'm so curious.
Homeing bullet!
All the designs are so cute, I know, right?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
I was pressing.
Oh, I don't think I have any more bullets left.
For support mage.
Okay.
I'll have to make more.
I have to make more support, mate.
I mean, more bullets for support, mate.
Take a...
Yay!
On
the way, out the way.
I need to get more hearts.
Please, please move.
Left click does the melee.
Oh, you looked it up.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Oh my gosh, you're right!
Oh, okay, but there's a slowdown on it.
Okay, okay.
So if I'm like...
Ah!
Thank you!
Oh my god, mid!
Mid!
Get him, I... Get him!
Ah!
Kid!
Oh my god, this guy has...
Pan lights!
Oh, I think we lost our mid.
I think we lost our mid maybe.
Oh no.
Okay, now we know how to fight.
Oh my goodness.
Let's increase the strength of this.
Oh, this is perfect.
Perfect timing.
Oh, perfect timing!
Oh yeah!
Perfect timing, baby!
Perfect timing.
Why are the mid so much stronger now?
There's another one right here.
Uh...
Cool down.
What did I just get?
Speed.
There was some more stuff up here, but...
Um...
Moro, let's increase our drones.
Oh my gosh.
Oh god.
Oh, they're really starting to get stronger.
You guys have taken damage!
Uh-oh.
Oh, we made it.
No!
I took damage!
Whatever will I do?
Oh no!
I took so much damage!
Where were you?
It's done.
The fight is finally over.
Oh yeah,
it totally looked like you were, you know what you were
doing out there.
I don't think it was anything special.
I was totally surprised at how calm and collected you were
despite everything.
Why does she look so...
I don't know, did you used to be a mercenary by any chance?
Ooh, it sounds like something out of a manga, huh?
Stories about ex-mercenaries are pretty popular now, aren't
they?
Is this a gotcha game?
No, it's not.
It's not a gotcha game.
You know that I'm just a regular college student, Nagisa.
Though I guess I have pretty good hand-eye coordination.
I mean, I'm pretty into shooter games.
She's a gamer!
You like video games?
Rinka's pretty famous in the gaming world.
She's ranked number one in whatchamacallit!
That was supposed to be a secret.
I mean, well, yeah, you're ranked number one because there's
no one left.
She's a gamer.
Yeah, she's probably a VTuber.
I don't know too much about video games, but it seems to be
an effective...
It's an effective tool.
It seems to be effective also.
Tool!
It seems to be an effective tool for preparing to fight!
But game skills don't equate to real-life skills
necessarily.
For starters, I can't fight if I don't have enough stamina.
I'm surprised some of these, this game isn't so new.
So I'm surprised some of these haven't been patched out.
The grammars.
Proof reading wasn't in the budget.
Please, curate.
I will play tester games, please.
Even though I missed Desperati earlier.
Those skills seem to have done you some good.
And even without being infected, you probably had the
potential to be a good fighter.
Oh, yeah.
I'm sure that's a compliment, but I don't know if I'm
particularly happy about it.
A little more palette swap or other differences between the
support maze and the zombie maze.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
For me, sometimes it is hard to see them, especially like...
Yeah, I do agree, though.
Maybe they could have, like, a sort of, like, maybe a red
outline or something so you can see them better.
Speaking of questions, I had one for you, actually.
Who are you?
Who are you exactly?
Oh, that's right.
I'm a little bit of a...
I was wondering that, too.
You have access to guns, so there's no way you're just some
regular civilian.
The mystery.
I'm very thankful that you saved me, but I don't think I can
fully trust you at this point.
And how are you able to make a vaccine in a modified made
calf?
So this is, I know what's happening here.
The, it's supposed to be the E with the little, the little
like, blip on top of it.
But I think the, it didn't read it, so it made into a...
Question mark.
No special characters, yeah.
E with a hat.
No, it doesn't have a hat.
It has a little...
Like, of all places.
I wasn't trying to hide anything.
I just didn't feel like there was an appropriate time to
explain everything.
Come on, we have another girl to save.
We can talk about it later.
An ahoye.
Yeah, an ahoye.
The E has an ahoye.
I'm no, Rinka, your suspicions are correct.
I'm no, I am no regular person.
What's more, I'm not entirely unrelated to this pandemic
either.
Elaborate.
What do you mean?
To better understand, I'll have to tell you about the MADS
virus, which is the cause of this pandemic.
This virus was originally developed in a secret, in secret
by a company.
called Arcana Industries.
Mads...
Mads Nicholson.
Yeah.
Arcana.
Aren't they like a globally famous company?
They're the ones who develop some zombie virus?
That's right.
I'm an Arcana industry Oh!
I'm a...
I'm an ex-researcher.
who is working on the development of the virus at our Kana
Industries.
But you look so young!
How are you a researcher?
I thought you were in middle school, maybe high school.
She's close to 30!
Oh my god!
She's in demand.
You're seriously older than me!
I was acting so casual around you.
My apologies.
Please just keep speaking the way you have been.
It's my fault we're not saying anything sooner.
I never would have thought that you'd be the one in charge
of developing the virus.
Did all this happen because of you?
Yes.
I was the one in charge of the research team.
Oh,
there were some issues and I ended up being fired.
Oh my god, this is some kind of sick retaliation for being
fired, is it?
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah, so I'm not going to be too bad for the pandemic.
So how did it get out?
I can see how you think that.
However, when the pandemic started, I was still in the
laboratory, pecking up my belongings.
I was still there.
I started to notice the other researchers turning into
zombies.
I grabbed the essentials and made a run for it.
My guns.
Well, you don't seem to be lying.
Oh my god.
If I want to stop this pandemic and perfect the virus or the
vaccine, it's important that we trust each other.
Oh my gosh.
My inner thoughts.
I'm perfecting the virus.
I mean, I mean the vaccine.
vaccine!
Of course, I didn't mean- oh, I have a Friday slip.
Can't believe Mint was actually a 5-inch high researcher of
maids the whole time.
What are you talking about?
Why am I only 5 inches?
Plus, you've already gone out of your way to save us.
So, ne, perfect a virus.
Obviously,
I understood the dangers of that virus.
I take full responsibility for such a horrendous tragedy.
If only I had destroyed that virus after its highly toxic
nature was discovered.
No,
I think it is her fault.
I think it is Nagisa, I think we're being a little too
forgiving here.
I think so.
I think it is 100% her fault.
It's not your fault, Kanon.
No one could have imagined something like this would happen.
I mean, if you're researching, if you're developing a virus
like this, Kanon did nothing wrong.
Oh,
I guess I'll be writing.
I might need to go get some coffee.
If you really feel that it's your fault, I guess the best
way to make up for it would be to complete the vaccine,
right?
For that, we'll be needing your help.
Of course.
Let's go get that idol girl.
But first, I think we need to upgrade a little bit.
I need the fiber.
Wait, how did I do that?
I said I had no fiber, right?
Wait, how did I... Oh, maybe I bought it?
Oh, oops.
Oh my gosh, I get the confirm and the go back button is
wrong.
Did it buy it for me?
Oh, I guess that's kind of...
I paid for it?
Oh, I guess that's handy.
And let's also...
We'll do one more?
Nice.
All right.
It buys the needed things if you have the money.
Oh, that's so handy.
So I don't have to go buy it myself.
Oh, nice.
Only eight more minutes.
Okay, let me go get my coffee real quick.
And then I will, um, I already have it made.
So let me go get some, or maybe tea.
I don't know.
I'll decide when I'm over there.
And, uh, then we'll do the next one.
Give me one second.
I'll be right back.
I accidentally put in way too much creamer.
No!
No, I accidentally put in way too much creamer!
And always had a nose.
Yeah, I was showing it off.
Did you guys like it?
You guys like my nose?
I got a package.
It's some Metal Gear goods that I pre-ordered.
Oh, they're so cute!
I got some stickers.
from someone off Etsy.
And they also had a cute little codec keychain that I got.
Knows where.
Can't you see it?
Can you make your own coffee?
Yeah, I have a French press.
That I use.
Oh my gosh, they're so cute.
They're so cute.
Okay.
Another W for Godot and black coffee.
Yeah, it's way too, it's way too much creamer.
It's basically, it's basically milk at this point.
Yeah, I messed up.
I messed up.
Okay, switch over and strike.
Nice.
Oh, only eight more minutes.
Okay.
Oh, she...
Okay, so she's really slow.
She's incredibly slow, but she hits multiple at a time.
She's so slow!
Oh my gosh.
Let's, uh...
Let's do a grenade.
Looks like me!
Ah, see, but it takes out a good amount of enemies at a
time.
Bye!
Take him out!
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, it's gonna take me a second to get used to this.
How is her melee?
The katana?
Let's do...
Increases close combat by 8%.
additionally affects some skills.
Let's try adding this.
Because it's...
Oh, wait.
What was it?
Oh, left hit.
Right?
But it's kind of...
The... I'm hoping the attack will, like, also help with,
um...
With, uh...
The...
Cool down, right?
That's another thing we can get is the cool down.
Let's do a magn...
Well, actually, we'll do the drone.
Okay.
Trying to get...
Oh!
Oh, oh, vacuum, vacuum, vacuum.
Vacuum.
Oh, we're not getting that vacuum, everybody.
What's her special skill?
Woo!
Wow!
Holy cow!
Oh, optimize.
Here we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Let's do the slash support.
And, uh...
Auto heal?
Because I need that.
Neat.
The cooldown is like so, it takes so long.
Oh, no, no, no.
Trying to get out of here.
Plus one drone.
More drones, please.
Hooy!
I have to survive for eight minutes?
This is gonna suck, you guys.
This is really gonna suck.
Oh, I'm not good.
with the I'm not good with the what's it called at all the
sniper oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh take him out that wasn't that
as many as I thought it would be um landline gumbare
oh nice nice nice oh there's some virus stuff oh that's
right I have no bullets for the support maids.
So we're on our...
I forgot to make more bullets for the support maids, you
guys.
We're on our own.
My CQC seems pretty decent.
Drill.
Drill, Drill.
I'm sorry, fellow maid.
Let's see.
More drown.
Nice.
I want that.
Give me that.
I'm being greedy.
But it's okay.
I'm being greedy, but it's okay.
I'll heal.
I heal a little bit.
And take him out.
Oh, why is she doing sideways?
No, I was pointing it down.
Oh, gosh.
I thought why is she only doing it in one direction?
You don't know you're beautiful.
That's what makes you beautiful.
Okay, it's not super wide either.
It's only horizontal.
Might also start to be good to increase defense in certain
things too.
Oh gosh, I need all these hearts.
Get out of my way.
Oh gosh.
Oh.
What does that mean?
The idol!
There we go.
Nice.
Yeah!
It does really look like me, doesn't it?
I'd win.
Nice.
One extra charge.
Oh, nice.
Let's do the magnetic field.
It's like a good passive to have, I think.
I think it's a good passive to have for...
Oh, gosh, oh, gosh.
Nice.
Oh, oh, oh, nice, nice.
Let's get that vacuum.
Nice.
My maid is a maid of justice.
Yeah.
Nice.
So it's horizontal only, but it does go both.
Oh, jeez.
I didn't even realize.
Optimize.
Yeah, there we go.
Nice, nice.
Kill him!
Oh gosh.
Oh no, oh no!
Nice.
I just took a little bit of damage there, but it's okay.
Or hit the end of the map.
I need more hearts.
Oh no, no, no.
Oh gosh.
Oh, it took a little bit of damage.
It's okay.
I heal eventually.
Oh gosh.
Oh, look.
when is my special oh I need more hearts run faster I'm dry
oh all of these are new hmm might be good too I'm out of
special charges
let's just wow not I thought
the special would charge over time.
But it doesn't.
It's really sad.
Makes me so sad.
Oh gosh, these guys are stronger.
Okay, there should be more hearts up here, you know, when I
killed people before.
When I was a murderer!
Here we are, here we are, here we are.
Yeah, start grabbing these.
Sweet.
Delicious.
Oh, they know the gemmy.
The evil...
Optimize.
Here we go, here we go.
Here's a lot.
Here's some.
Nice.
There's a sweet gem.
Oh, you!
Where'd the gem go?
Oh, oh, you!
How much more do I...
Oh, my gosh.
I still have so much more time.
Guys.
Oh,
nice.
Oh, yeah.
I think the grenade might be good to optimize or have more
of.
Oh, you, you.
You, you, you.
Oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh,
oh, gosh.
Come.
Oh, don't put you in there.
That's, like, counterproductive though.
That's not what I want.
Don't go in there.
No!
You know what?
We're using the slash a lot, so I think it's good to have.
Come on, come on, come on.
Yeah!
No!
Down, down, down.
Aim down.
Oh my god, just not enough.
Oh my god.
There it is!
Yippee!
Give me the sweet bucks.
Oh!
I got three!
Oh my gosh.
Let's go.
Just playing with the game with some cute maids.
Don't kill me.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Well, just one minute left!
Just one minute left!
I think we're fine now, honestly.
think we're more than good to be honest kind
of cleared out a bunch of the big horde so sometimes like
her shot does so good of damage maybe there's like maybe she
can like crit stuff and you know oh oopsie slash get out of
my way mental gaming I
wish I could convert some of these maids to my side.
They would make such a great army.
The maid army.
Increase healing.
We only have 10 seconds.
We're good.
Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Blah blah blah blah blah.
Yubby!
So our crit rate is 15%.
Ah okay okay.
Yay.
What are the odds that the maid that looks like you uses a
sniper rifle?
I don't know what to tell.
She doesn't look exactly like me.
You know?
We still have strength to it.
How much money do we have?
The sprite does.
11,000!
Okay, we're close.
But.
Oh, but.
But she's like my big sister.
I do kind of like using the katana.
So, I think I might actually...
Okay.
And the sniper rifle is not super easy, but it's not bad.
Is this map even remotely close to Akiba?
The CG scenes are, like, almost super accurate.
Actually, I think the...
Map is actually kind of accurate, too.
You know what?
Yeah.
Let's just upgrade the sniper rifle.
I think we should be good there.
Like this map.
So if this is...
If this is UDX, then this would be the main street of
Akihabara, right?
Oh, I'm kind of blocking some of it.
This would be the main street, Chuo Dori.
This is actually, yeah, pretty accurate.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is the train station, because UDX you go here, and
train station would be right here.
Mm-mm-mm-mm-mm.
And, uh...
Yeah, this is basically the size of Akihabara even, so...
It's pretty accurate.
Oh, bullets!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, you guys saved me.
Thank you.
You guys saved me.
workshop.
Buy items.
Let's do five.
Unking!
Mint enters her mind palace and can view I as a top top.
Yeah, just call me Mint's lock homes.
Defeat all enemies.
Easy.
Let's go!
This game is so much fun.
Oh my gosh.
It basically scratches every single one of my itches.
Like being like a visual novel and also...
Um...
Being a little etchy and cute, and having maids in the
vampire survivors part.
Like every bit of it, I'm just like...
Yeah, I love this.
The sprites are really cute.
They are!
They kind of remind me of Phantom Breaker.
Does anyone else get that kind of vibe from them?
Toilet paper!
I think that's the fiber.
Oh, there's like more obstacles and stuff now.
It's kind of fun.
Mint.
Mint Tante.
Reminds me of Holocure.
Yes, yes.
Well, Holocure is also based off of vampire survivors,
right?
So it's all the same.
A little bit.
Let's add more...
I like these guys.
I don't know if they even do that much, but...
They work for me.
I like having kind of a barrier.
They do enough.
They do a little bit.
I can see it working.
Optimize.
I didn't realize that my drones could run out.
That's so messed up.
More drones!
Oh.
The electric drones seem good when they're active, they're
just not active very long.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're right.
Um...
It says that they have a cooldown, but I didn't realize that
they just disappeared altogether.
It's kind of messed up.
Yeah!
Nice.
Um...
Optimize.
Oops.
I didn't realize I was still on a cooldown.
Sometimes I forget to aim when I'm trying to like find.
Let's see.
Oh, the HP auto-healing.
Let's get that for sure.
Requires a charging period.
do your pulls for Dressina.
I already did them, Scourge, yeah.
I have already done them and I got her after many a pull.
I got her after many a pull, but I still got her
nonetheless.
Nice.
Yeah, since there's a lot of enemies and we're trying, it's
to defeat all of them.
Having the missiles and grenades and stuff is good, I think.
Yeah.
Rip Oymol.
Screw Oymol.
Wait, what's that little arrow pointing to?
Do you see that?
You see that?
What are we heading to?
Oh!
We killed this special thing, I didn't even notice.
Oh my god.
Oh, I wasted that.
My bad.
There we go.
Yeah, screw Lionbow!
Okay.
So it does alert you when you have dropped something like
that, which is nice.
I always appreciate when games do that.
Thank you, games.
Wish I could get a vacuum.
There's a lot of hearts, but they're all really spread out.
Drone, strength.
Oh, here's another one.
Oh, perfect.
He gave her so much gotcha luck by cursing her again.
That girl doesn't need any gotcha luck at all.
She's like, oh, ooh, ooh.
Oh, my gotcha luck is so bad.
Ooh, ooh.
She had, like, a hundred, a hundred thousand plus jemmies.
What, what gotcha luck do you need?
You're, you're just a whale.
It doesn't matter about your luck.
You're going to get them anyway.
Leave us plebeians alone Us basically free to play Let the
whales do their thing But don't Don't take away the luck of
us plebs
Every time you click off the stream She started laughing at
your most fortune I believe that Mike Tyson's ass!
You're eating!
No, girl.
You ate.
Thanks for the five giftings.
The legend.
I really appreciate you always being around.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm honored to be visited by a legend.
You know?
I wonder how long this...
one is.
It's to feed all the enemies, but they seem very... It
doesn't seem like very many guys here.
Not very many people around anymore.
Zombies, are you all dead?
Are you all gone?
Were you all underneath this car?
Is this where you guys are?
Zombies.
Oh, hey, hey, hey.
Don't double.
That will tame me.
Nice.
Crease is shooting streams by 8%.
I wonder if this one would be good to have too.
Yeah!
Wait.
I mean... Oh no!
I'm taking damage!
Oh no!
I'm... I'm taking damage!
In my edge made game.
Whatever will I do if I take too much damage?
Oh!
Oh, don't gang up on me!
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, you guys!
Oh no, I'm gaming too hard.
I can't.
I can't lose clothes.
They need to make the game harder.
So that I can lose more clothes.
Oh no, I'm just gonna a pro gamer.
Make the game more difficult.
Um...
I guess we'll do the shot support.
It says it affects other stuff, too.
I wonder what it affects.
Oh, nice.
Minto, when she plays Delta.
Only 30!
Oh, wait, there's another gun!
Come on.
Nice.
Give me more money.
Senron Kagura levels of logic.
Whoa, we got a lot of money there, you guys.
I'm just gonna start running into them.
Come on.
Take off my clouds!
Take my clouds!
Yeah!
Okay.
Look how much my health has increased.
It's fine, you know?
How many more guys are there?
I'm 2OP.
I'm 2OP, you guys.
I'm actually 2OP, I think.
Regen is pretty busted?
Yeah, 100%.
It really is.
Oh, vacuum.
Oh, oh, sorry.
Don't hurt me.
Regains my special skill.
You know what, let's just use it.
Everything's gonna be maxed at this point.
I'm gonna have to... I have room for other skills.
I don't know.
I haven't decided what I want to hit yet.
Which is why I'm just maxing everything else out.
This one was like, destroy all the enemies, wasn't it?
When does it end?
This level is long.
Yeah, for real.
There's so many enemies.
Oh, nice.
Oh!
They all disappeared.
We did it!
It was 2,197 specifically.
Who knew being a maid was such hard work in serving and
fighting?
I know, right?
It's never easy for us.
I lost my clothes, but I'm still S-rank, baby!
Let's go to the next one.
I really just want to, I really just want to find the new
girl.
Oh, defeat the boss!
Here we go!
You guys.
Here we go.
Wait.
Before I do that, actually.
I didn't even, I didn't even recruit any new girls.
Keep from being drama free.
Tough month, huh?
Wait, what do you mean?
What did I say?
What did I do?
Upgrades?
But I'm saving up for the hairpin.
You know who cares about the hairpin?
I'm all about that drama, baby.
Level 6.
Level 5.
That should be good.
That should be enough.
Let's strike.
Will you play this game entirely or just kind of off stream?
I don't know yet.
I think I'll probably play...
You know, I can probably stream it while I'm in Japan.
This is a perfect game to stream.
I'm trying to find like games that I can play also in Japan.
Ones that aren't too difficult.
For me to like...
Because, you know, playing on a laptop.
Playing on a laptop is not always easy.
Hmm.
Hollow cure arc?
I...
Maybe.
I'll probably play that too.
Probably play that while I'm in Japan too.
Everything's a bit cleaner now, huh?
I never expected there to be so many zombies.
It's to be expected when you shoot a zombie.
off such flashy fireworks.
Tyler!
Look, I'm the man, bush, and thank you.
That might not be the only reason that there were a ton of
them, though.
But, okay, one thing that has been kind of making me not
want to play, well, not not want to play it, has been making
me wary of playing Hollow Cure is I know a lot of people are
very how do I say?
They're very set in their how you should play the game ways.
Very backseating.
So, you know, they're just like, this is the meta.
Why are you playing like this?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So, I don't know.
I'll have to be, I'll have to be in a, you know, one of
those, in a mood where I'm prepared for people to backseat
me.
You know what I mean?
Because usually, you know, some days I'm okay with it and
some days I'll be like oh my gosh I cannot handle it right
now so um yeah yeah but I have been wanting to play it I've
been like oh my gosh I want to do holo cure I played the one
corona game it was so much fun and I played that actually
off stream as well too I kept playing it but um overly eager
passengers yes you must fish in only fish fishing is the
only game but um corone box yeah yeah that one's really fine
to play we have our own style of play and that is okay see
that's like a really reasonable way to think about things
but there are also people that just get very passionate and
i understand they're just Like, I'm excited.
But, you know, for those kinds of passionate people, just
play the game yourself.
But if you're just like, I don't like the way this VTuber's
playing the game, then go do it yourself.
Just go play it yourself.
Anyway.
That might not be the only reason there were a ton of them,
though.
Two.
O-B-Y-A-O-B-Y-O-B-N.
Oh, Obin from Bloons, handle it so true have you figured
something out mr.
Inka
oh it's kind of obvious from the location but I guess you'll
see once we go inside definitely a VTuber moment
stop this is the AKB theater
This is the AKB theater, no way!
Oh my gosh, that's so funny!
Have you thought about playing the AquaVian?
Oh, oh!
Personally, like, on my personal time, yes.
But on stream, I don't know.
I don't know, maybe.
What's that?
There's a group called AKB48, and they had their beginnings,
their humble beginnings, in the theater in the Don Quixote
of Akihabara.
specifically that theater because each year they put a
different stripe of tape on the on the pillars so that's how
you can tell
you didn't do anything wrong oh already Rex been here just
election stuff and beast stuff what we can all come here and
be drama free oh yeah we don't we don't talk about anything
at all We all...
I like to just hang out and chill.
Yeah.
I don't know what's going on.
I only know Heavy Rotation Song.
That's okay.
I like that song too.
I've been to Donkey there many times.
I had a theater.
Yeah, you have to apply online for a ticket.
You didn't have to do that in the past.
But now...
I mean, way, way in the past.
But it's hard to get tickets for.
it but uh but yeah they have a show almost every day made
for president made for president i was made to be number one
from the footage i have it appears to be a normal shopping
mall am i missing something Oh,
right.
Of course you don't know Kanon.
This is the holy ground for underground idols.
There are live performances here every day.
If an outbreak were to occur during one of the performances,
it would be disastrous, huh?
Even though we say underground idols, this place is pretty
famous.
Anyone who performed here would have had quite the fan base.
They're going to show the infamous column that impedes the
view of like 30% of the seats.
Oh, gosh.
Then when you add in the staff, that's quite a lot of
people, don't you think?
Stop spoiling the story.
No doubt.
It's actually funny, too, because you can't bring UOs.
UOs are, like, pen lights that are not pen lights, but
they're, like, glow sticks that when you break them, they
turn super duper bright.
But people in the theater, like, they've broken them so many
times that they had to, like, ban them.
Not because they're so bright, just because they keep
breaking them.
Nagisa, look.
Sometimes it is painful to watch a streamer becoming
frustrated because she's actively making the game harder on
herself without even realizing it, so I can sympathize with
helping to an extent.
I get that mentality, for sure.
I think also, though, people are so...
Certain people can be very quick to jump and not allow
someone to learn.
You know, so it's just like, it's kind of a balance.
Like, I think that's why a lot of streamers will have like,
they'll be like, okay, I'm ready for backseating now, you
know, they'll kind of, because everybody, you know,
especially if someone's, especially if someone is playing a
game for the first time, they will not know how to play it.
And so you have to give them a chance to learn how to learn
the controls.
And, you know, it's, I think it's way more rewarding for
someone to be playing a game and then you know be really
frustrated and be like ah this isn't working this isn't
working and then a certain control clicks and they're just
like oh it oh so that's how you do it you know i think so at
least it's okay to have a hard time yeah everybody struggles
sometimes we're all on the struggle bus especially me then
chat spams no help They're like, I need help now.
No help.
And sometimes it's just skill issue.
Why would there be fireworks in this place?
This confirms it.
There are a bunch of fireworks missing from the shelves.
The survivors must have used them.
Oh my god, my cat.
I thought I didn't see you.
They're pies.
Oh my gosh, I felt you, but I didn't see you.
Oh my god.
You little plopping girl.
You're so crazy.
She's rolling on the ground.
Let me let my cat out.
She's always hanging out with me.
I love her.
I love you little girl.
You're so stinky.
You're so cute.
What are you doing?
You're stretching.
You're being cute girl.
You're so crazy.
You're crazy girl, you know that, you're crazy.
You're crazy.
Okay, I'll be right back.
One month without pies, don't remind me, okay, please.
I'll be right back, let me let her out.
It's funny because when I stream with Po...
Bu-Taro?
When I stream with Bu-Taro, he...
He...
He hates...
As soon as I start streaming, he wants out of my room.
But with Paz, she likes to hang around.
Sorry.
I...
I obviously combined Paz and Butaro together.
You know?
He's stream shy.
Yeah.
I have two cats if nobody knows if you don't know I have I
have Paz I just got her recently and then I have Butaro he's
my little guy I too combine my cats all the time yeah but
basically might as well be him any signs of the survivors
both are allegedly quite stinky Nagisa, cover it up!
Oh, watch out, Nagisa!
Cue it!
Cute!
Isn't that Maidle 5's Arisa?
Maidle 5?
She's a cute little girl.
She's a five-year-old girl,
I love my Chika idols.
But perhaps she was the one who called for help.
Maybe we didn't make it in, make it on time.
No, hold on a sec.
It looks like she hasn't fully transformed yet.
So she's the same as us?
Oh my God, the maid, the maid buff.
Maid buff, maid buff.
It appears so.
It may be that she's also, oh, she's always carried, oh,
she, it may be that she's always carried the antibodies, but
there's also a chance that she might have developed them.
Who's better, Sechomaru or Sephiroth?
What the hell?
I'm not really a fan of either of them.
That doesn't matter now.
We still have a chance to save her, so we should hurry it
up.
Oh my gosh in the theater!
This is so cute!
In the theater!
Yeah!
Oh no, all the seats and everything!
Um, grenade!
Where's the...
Where's the... Oh my goodness.
Oh no, the seats are...
Okay.
An obstacle.
Got it.
Understood.
Why?
Stop throwing it that way.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
Um.
Let's do a slash.
Nice.
Oh.
This game has such awesome music.
Why is it so fun?
I want to get closer to the stage.
I'm gonna go cheer on my Yoshi!
I like the miniature missiles too.
I think they're pretty good.
Toilet paper!
I haven't needed things like the shields yet, so...
Oh, hello Otaku-chan!
a maid there but it's like a maze in here being able to like
get over to the nice oh yeah oh you are oh the state oh you
don't want to get trapped in here it's pretty bad you don't
want to get trapped in here it's pretty bad time to update
my wish list it is fine though right most of the grenades
she can throw like across the barriers and stuff is so good
toilet paper
Oh my god.
They're all funneling through here.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Wow!
Oh, wait a bit of...
Yeah, get out of my face.
Nice!
This is such a small map, I know, right?
Yeah, I can't.
I can see it becoming bad too.
Oh!
Oh, this is invisibility!
This is the invis- Oh, well, it doesn't last very long and
they can still see me, I think!
Nice!
Nice too!
Let's see this.
Where's the boss?
Where's she at?
I think we have to go through it a little bit and then we
get to it, right?
Oh,
I'm getting trapped again.
Nice, nice.
Die zombie!
Give me money!
I don't know why do I need money in the apocalypse.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh, the pillars!
Let's do the incendiary grenade.
A nice passive one.
Oops, I don't even know what I just attacked.
I'll take that.
Thank you very much.
Whoa!
Oh, oh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Don't get...
The missiles are so good.
Holy moly.
This is the pillar.
Let's get some support drones.
Alright.
If we want to talk meta, the drone meta.
Baby.
This is a nice spot to be in, maybe.
Look at all that blah.
Oh my god, there's so many girls up there!
Oh, flamethrowers!
There's two of
them.
Yeah!
Drone meta is real.
Take them out!
I'm so effective!
There's no one else to kill!
Oh, nice.
The drones should get CG art too.
So true.
Oh, I was not even.
Not bad.
I don't, because I don't like, you know, at least with the
stage, I can have like a...
Oh gosh.
Ah!
Oh!
At least with the stage, I can have, like, a wall.
I don't know.
Nice.
There we go.
I like this area way better.
Because also the chairs kind of block them, too.
Just ends up being a pretty decent spot, I'd say.
Oh my gosh, look at all of them fuddling through here.
Come on, babies!
Oh no!
No, no, no!
Oh no, no.
I heal so fast, though.
I don't know why I'm even worried about taking damage.
I'd have to be, like, super...
Super tackled to be in a bad spot, you know?
Just stand still.
Yeah, pretty much.
And the missiles are OP, for real.
Oh, oh, she's here!
She's here!
oh there she is oh my god stop she's the cutest ever stop
she's hopping at me oh my god she's perfect oh i think
almost oh god oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh oh no does that mean
all of the bosses are We're gonna have the same fighting
style.
I wonder.
Can you recruit her?
Yeah, baby.
That's what we're gonna do.
She's so cute.
I need her on my team.
I need her, I need her, I need her, I need her.
I need her, I need her, I need her.
This game is very obviously not for the gameplay though.
Because there's so much time in between her like between her
doing this attack you know oh no the little tiny missile
it's like a Jiang Shi I know it's so cute
yuppie I saw your super chat what did you ask I always hated
mint flavored things because of you I gave it another chance
and I actually like it now
yuppie time to cure everybody
Time to cure.
Sina can't be waiting.
We got Anisa!
Lay her down here, please.
We'll start the procedure immediately.
I'm in this kind of a situation.
So, when you think of it, I was in a similar state to her,
right?
Thinking about it logically, it's a miracle that I was able
to come to my senses.
I'm ready to dork it.
It'll all work out.
Canon knows what she's doing.
You should know better than anyone, right, Minka?
Yeah, you're right.
Let's pray for the best.
I'll begin the procedure.
should be in quotes.
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy.
Oh, she's perfect!
Stop, she's perfect!
Oh god!
Shuko, shuko, shuko.
Oh god, she's so perfect!
Oh, don't do it, don't change her!
I love her as she is!
Oh god, she's so cute.
Oh no, she's so...
She's so my time, it hurts!
No!
Yiggo, yiggo, yiggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo,
shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, everybody let's shuggo
together!
Shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo,
shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo,
shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shuggo, shug
go, shuggo, medicine!
It's medicine, you guys!
This is a medicinal procedure.
I can't keep defending my Yoshi like this.
This is a medical procedure!
Shikou shikou shikou shikou shikou shikou shikou shikou
shikou shikou shikou shikou shikou shikou Shukui, shukui,
shukui, shukui!
Medicine!
I like the way we just splatter it on her.
She's gonna cure!
Oh, she's so cute!
Shukui, shukui, shukui, shukui!
That's right.
There's why you're the best boss.
Shukui, shukui, shukui, shukui, shukui!
Get cured!
Shuko, Shuko, Shuko!
Shuko, Shuko!
Where'd the sharp teeth go?
I know.
It's such a downgrade, isn't it?
Don't Shuko too hard.
You might damage the vaccine bottle.
Sometimes I rip the skin.
Use medicine!
Oh.
You know what's a really good part is right here.
This right here.
What is this expression?
In the end,
we were only able to save Arisa, huh?
No.
I thought there might be more survivors, but it seems they
were all turned into zombies.
This is a triumph of the digital art.
Please don't blame yourselves.
In fact, we should be happy that we were able to save Miss
Arisa.
So, Arisa also had the antibodies.
Yes.
And because of them, she was able to prolong the
zombification process compared to the average victim.
Wow, it seems like, what are the odds that three people in
Akihabara all have the antibodies?
Like what are the odds?
Anime.
I wonder how many people out there have these antibodies.
Yeah, I've been wondering, yeah, me too, I've been wondering
about that.
Right.
When you think of it, shouldn't there be more people?
Only having the three of us seems like too few.
The pinnacle of these digital media.
Made armor real.
Oh.
but the odds are pretty low.
Oh, I can't be certain, but the odds are pretty low.
It'd be something like 1 in 10,000 or 1 in 100,000.
I'd win.
Give me them gotcha rates.
Sorry.
Miss Nagisa, Miss Binka, and Miss Arisa, the odds of the
three of you were in the same area during a pandemic like
this is nothing short of a miracle.
Oh no, she's perfect.
Yes, it is indeed a miracle.
I was one of the chosen ones after all.
Oh my god.
She's perfect.
Thank you for the captain!
Fifty-gifted one!
Drowing taco, thank you!
Okay, fine, I will now buy this game.
Oh,
it appears you know my name.
Proof that I am indeed one of the chosen few.
You cousins rescued me, correct?
Taki thanks for the five gift and thank you!
Shadow and even lower the gift and thank you!
I offer you my thanks.
Though I am a child of destiny, even I have my limits and
would have died without your assistance.
I hope work wasn't too hard for you.
She just called us peasants.
And I wish she'd do it again.
During our live, the zombies swarmed in.
It was utter pandemonium.
Our worshippers succumbed to the virus in mere silence.
Second!
Yes, my master!
Welcome back, Kuroneko.
At first I was able to hide among several loyal followers,
but at soon they could no longer resist their fear, and one
after the other ran away.
Oh, doesn't sound very loyal at all.
They ran away, like, leaving you all but alone?
Shunim-Eyed.
Mint, what have you unleashed?
What a humble person.
I must dedicate my life.
I'm sure in their minds it was a tactical retreat, though
most of them had lost the capacity for rational thought.
Her voice sounds kind of like
I cannot condemn those brave young men and women, for even I
felt an ounce of fear seep into my bones.
My Oshi is a simp like me, for real, for real.
So which maid is so far the cutest besides you?
Do you have to ask?
So let me get the same thing.
straight you were the one that shot off the fireworks right
you guys hear it right so funny that is correct um I had
exhausted all of the resources and what left was left no
choice but in the end it ended up being a beacon for those
cursed beings.
I thought I had met my end when they surrounded me, but the
fact that I am here now speaks a great deal.
You seem to be a rather strange individual.
More like she's delusional.
Thank you!
How do I say your name?
A-S-A-Fix?
A-S-Fix?
These maids are pretty cute, but Mint is still the cutest
one.
Stop it!
Stop it.
You really are unique, aren't you, Arisa?
That's what makes you adorable!
Oh,
I bet it was a major shock for you though.
I mean, you lost all your friends who were in the same idol
group, right?
I shall never forget the fallen, for they were my comrades
and arms, warriors bent on saving the world through song.
People died, Arisha.
People die.
It's so tragic that she has brain damage now, right?
But there's nothing to be saddened about.
Their souls still live on within me.
You're strong, Arisa.
That I am.
That's why I'm the child of destiny who will one day save
this planet.
Hold it, I just realized.
Oh.
What?
You two are zombie hunters, are you not?
And what?
You two are zombie hunters, correct?
Are you not working with a blonde-haired ninja?
What?
Come again?
You're that ninja.
Must be another one of her delusions.
There's a lady who appears when zombies approach.
A true savior for humanity.
She saved you but then left you to die apparently.
saved my life, but immediately vanished without stating her
name.
Shortly after I was cornered once again, leading me to go
into hiding.
Believe it.
Yeah, true.
Perhaps her motives aren't to save people.
I mean, if she was trying to do that, she would have gotten
you to safety, right?
A blonde ninja.
A kimpatsu ninja.
We can't say that for certain.
It's difficult to carry someone to safety while moving.
She might have just done what she was capable of at the
time.
Hmm, something seems aww.
But
that's awesome.
There's someone else other than us that's fighting the
zombies.
And hearing your story, Arisa, she seems to be an incredible
fighter.
Maybe we can befriend her since we have similar goals.
Doki is not a ninja.
Doki ninja outfit win.
She's a Western ninja.
Can cowboys be considered Western ninjas, maybe?
Putting our motives aside for one second, the fact that she
can fight zombies might mean she's a normal human either.
Ooh.
Maybe.
No, they're Western samurai.
Oh, you're right, you're right.
They're Western samurai.
True, true, true.
A person with antibodies.
She might even be like you, Miss Nagisa.
Never having undergone transformation.
And perhaps it's as Miss Nagisa says, said she might
actually cooperate with us.
What do you do, Nagisa?
What do you do?
What's the plan, Nagisa?
Who am I kidding?
I already know your answer.
Please!
Who put it?
I don't want to be a grammar police, but please!
Please!
Of course we're gonna go look for her.
What's that saying?
The more the merrier?
You are answer.
You are answer!
Allow me to join you on the search for the blonde-haired
ninja.
Do not fret, my comrades!
I am the chosen one!
I will never fall to those zombie scum!
Ah!
Oh!
Scum.
Arisa Hikami Oh, sorry I thought it was like one word Arisa
Hikami Nice Headband A
What's headband A mean?
Lebus
She's so cute Let me touch her Yeah.
Chuni Mintopo Halloween special win.
Mmm.
What?
Wait,
I can touch your feet.
What?
Touching the feet does nothing?
No reaction to the feet.
You know what?
It's to make it fair, you guys.
It's to make it fair.
Because we can't touch their feet.
It would be unfair if she reacted to her feet and we
wouldn't be able to touch any other feet.
You know?
Well, guys, I have another collab hour so i think that's
where we're gonna leave it off here i'm just gonna save just
in case
game saved we got three girls who was who also uh how do i
get to the main menu
there's even there's a lot of sub stories too oh there's a
lot of sub stories wow The harem is taking shape.
And we have a headband we can buy now.
How much is it?
Oh gosh.
35.
Titan silver.
So I have enough Titan silver.
I just need...
I need the money.
Oh, I'm close to 20,000 though.
I'm close, actually.
Increases attack.
Increases power and point growth.
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
But yeah, this has been so much fun!
This has been so much fun.
Oh my gosh, I just noticed that Nagisa has like a half...
A half...
What's the word?
Hime cut!
Everybody's so cute!
All of them are so cute!
They're so cute!
Thank you for the streaming, though.
Thank you!
Thanks, guys, for hanging out with me, allowing me to play
this silly little, uh, little, um, etchy game about maids
and zombies.
My favorite things ever.
How do I go back to the main menu?
No, no, no, back, back, back, back.
Help!
Oh, return a title!
There we go.
Let's see, who else do we have?
Oh, there's our ninja!
There's Onesa.
Holy.
There's a ghost maid and beast tamer.
What?
No way.
Wow.
Wait, she uses a chainsaw.
She's even more perfect.
Oh my god.
I'm so excited.
Oh gosh.
I can't wait to play as her.
Um.
The song makes me just what a headbang, you know?
She packs a chainsaw.
Oh, and, like, the shine.
Oh, my gosh.
So awesome.
Best character.
Look at, I think they need to get new uniforms.
They're about to bust out of these.
But also, busting makes me feel good.
Anyways, guys, thanks for Made of the Dead.
We'll probably continue it eventually.
wins probably sometime in Japan you know and yeah I'm gonna
go get some food before next collab in the pinned message
you'll see that I'm collabing with Barry and Ashton later on
we'll be being silly goofy Disney adults so mmm mmm great
stream Minto thank you and yeah I'm gonna go get some stuff
for my throat even.
I'm gonna drink some throat tea and get some dinner.
I suggest you guys do the same.
And I'll see you guys later.
Thank you so much for watching me!
I know it was really, really early, different from my time
usually, but I appreciate you watching and hanging out with
me today!
Thank you!
I'll see you guys later!
Otsu mitau!
Otsu bastion!
Otsu...
Otsu mitau.
Eat'a-lashai!
Eat'a-dashai!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
See you guys later!
Bye-bye!